ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY, WELCOME.
THIS IS THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE, AND IT
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER, AS I
THINK YOU CAN SEE BY LOOKING AT
THE DAIS, WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE WILL MEET IN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND AS YOU KNOW,
WE GO AND FILE ORDER. BUT BUT
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY HAS
BEEN HERE FOR 30 MINUTES AND
SHE'S GOT A PRESS CONFERENCE.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
DIRECTLY TO FILE ITEM 13 AB 3203
WITH A MOTION OF Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE A, WITNESSES OR NOT,
BUT THE COMMITTEE RULES, TWO
SPEAKERS, TWO MINUTES EACH.
WE'LL KEEP IT SHORT. AND WITH
THAT FLOOR IS YOURS. GREAT.
GOOD, GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, AB 3203 WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLERS TO
CONTINUE SELLING THEIR PRODUCTS
ONLINE AND SHIPPING THEM
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS, JUST LIKE
THE WINE AND BEER INDUSTRIES DO.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 200 CRAFT
DISTILLERS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE
FAMILY OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT EMPLOY 5 TO 10 PEOPLE
DURING THE HEIGHT OF COVID
PANDEMIC, GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL,
BEVERAGE AND CONTROL AUTHORIZED
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLERS FROM
MARCH TO MARCH OF 2020 TO MARCH
OF 2022. THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED THIS PRIVILEGE UNTIL
2023 AND AGAIN UNTIL 2024.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ONLINE SALES
AND SHIPPING AUTHORIZATION
EXPIRES AT THE END OF 2025. AB
3203 SIMPLY EXTENDS THIS
AUTHORIZATION UNTIL JANUARY
2026. MEMBERS. THIS PRIVILEGE
HAS BEEN A LIFELINE, ALLOWING
DISTILLERIES IN THE STATE TO
OFFSET REVENUES LOST TO THE
IMPACTS OF COVID AND INCREASE
THEIR PRESENCE IN A MARKET WHERE
THEY SIMPLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
SHELF SPACE. IN MOST RETAIL
OUTLETS. I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT TO HELP THE CRAFT
DISTILLING INDUSTRY FOR ONE MORE
YEAR. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY,
I HAVE NATE SULLIVAN FROM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT
DISTILLERS GUILD AND BO BILL
FROM THE ON BEHALF OF UPS FLOOR
IS YOURS CHAIR AND MEMBERS. NATE
SULLIVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLERS
ASSOCIATION, APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YOU'VE PASSED THESE
BILLS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THAT THEY'VE ALLOWED OUR
CRAFT DISTILLERIES AROUND THE
STATE, ABOUT 200 OF THEM TO STAY
OPEN, THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL,
JOB CREATION OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE SMALL BUSINESSES BECAUSE
WITHOUT THIS ABILITY, THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE OVER 30% OF THEIR
SALES. SO THAT THIS ALLOWS THEM
TO GROW AND EXPAND. AND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU, MR.
BILLER. MR. CHAIRMAN, SENATORS
BOW BILLER ON BEHALF OF BRUCE
DOUBLE D MACRAE AND UPS. WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. IN
OUR LETTER, WE'VE DETAILED THE
FACT THAT IT'S BEEN A GREAT
SUCCESS IN THE WINE INDUSTRY
OVER THE MANY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
MOVING IT, AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM THAT WANT TO ADD ME TO
TESTIMONY SO THAT BE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS,
STACEY DOOLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIA,
OUR SMALL FAMILY WINEMAKERS
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY MEMBERS HERE
IN OPPOSITION. AND YOU CAN GO
AHEAD AND GIVE TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. MIKE,
SKIP ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL
JUSTICE, THIS BILL FUNDAMENTALLY
UNDERMINES THE THREE TIER
SYSTEM. IT MAKES IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO CONSISTENTLY
ENGAGE IN RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE PRACTICE, AND IT CREATES
A NEARLY INSURMOUNTABLE
CHALLENGE FOR ABC, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE A LIFELINE FOR THE SMALL
DISTILLERS. BUT SINCE COVID, THE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING HAS,
HELPED TO SPUR A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATHS, WHICH ARE NOW TOPPING
OVER 19,000 A YEAR FROM LESS
THAN 12,000 BEFORE COVID. WE
ASKED FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO ADD ME TO
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS. I'M SURE
YOU'RE GOING TO LET US KNOW.
IT'S A GREAT BILL, BUT GO AHEAD,
I. I WILL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD. IN THE TIME THAT
YOU'VE YOU'VE THE BILL'S BEEN
WELL, IT'S BEEN THE LAW TO GO
AHEAD AND DO THIS. HAVE THE
PROPRIETORS REPORTED BACK ANY
NEGATIVE THAT YOU'VE HEARD OF?
NO NEGATIVE ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND THIS IS WHAT I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE OUR SMALL BUSINESS.
BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR IF THEY'VE
HAD PROBLEMS WITH THIS. NO, THEY
HAVE BEEN DELIGHTED BECAUSE IT
GAVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN
UP A MARKET THAT THEY WERE
UNABLE TO TAP INTO. SO I ONLY
HEAR GOOD THINGS ABOUT IT. THE
FEW THAT I HEAR THAT ARE LIKE
QUESTIONING IS JUST LIKE, CAN
YOU EXTEND IT FOR EVEN LONGER?
BUT AT THIS POINT, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN GO THROUGH 2026
AND CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND MAKE
SURE THE DATA IS THERE, THAT
THIS IS A GOOD PROGRAM. OKAY. SO
I'LL MOVE THE BILL AND WE'LL
HAVE A MOTION WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. I'LL JUST CLOSING
COMMENTS AND THEN YOU CAN CLOSE.
SO LAST TIME WE DID THIS BILL WE
HAD THE PROPRIETOR FROM
VILLICANA WHICH IS UP IN, THE
PASO ROBLES AREA, WHICH IS A
FIVE HOUR DRIVE FROM MY HOUSE. I
LOVE I LOVE THEIR CUCUMBER
VODKA, BUT I DON'T WANT TO DRIVE
FIVE HOURS TO BUY A BOTTLE. I
DON'T WANT YOU TO EITHER,
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO LAST ME
THREE YEARS. THAT'S AN EXPENSIVE
BOTTLE OF VODKA, RIGHT? EXACTLY
SO THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN GREAT
FOR THAT. SO WITH THAT, I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND YOU
MAY CLOSE Ó. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU KNOW, I HAVE A YOUNG
DISTILLER RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
FROM ME AND IT'S SO NICE TO SEE
THAT HE HAS ANOTHER OPTION FOR
HIS SMALL BUSINESS. AND SO I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL DONE. THANK YOU.
WHO ELSE DO WE HAVE IN THE ROOM
HERE? WE HAVE DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SO LET'S SEE. WOW, YOU GUYS ARE
ALL SNEAKING IN EARLY. SO THIS
IS FILE ITEM TEN A B 2543. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHERE I WILL
SEE IT AGAIN WITH THAT, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS. ALL
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. WHEN SMALL BUSINESS
THRIVES IN CALIFORNIA'S. IN
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA THRIVES.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2543 ENSURES THAT
ELIGIBLE BUSINESS OWNERS,
INCLUDING DACA ENTREPRENEUR
YEARS, ARE ABLE TO REGISTER
THEIR BUSINESSES WITH THE STATE
AS A CERTIFIED SMALL BUSINESS,
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IN RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF SMALL BUSINESSES,
CALIFORNIA VÀ ESTABLISHED THE
CERTIFIED SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM
I'M A SMALL BUSINESS, WHICH IS
CERTIFIED UNDER THIS PROGRAM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A NUMBER OF
BENEFITS SUCH AS BIDDING
PREFERENCES, PROMPT PAYMENT OF
STATE CONTRACTS, AND AS A SMALL
BUSINESS QUALIFIERS FOR PRIME
CONTRACTORS REQUIRED TO
SUBCONTRACT WITH A SPECIFIED
PERCENTAGE OF SMALL BUSINESSES.
DESPITE THEIR IMPORTANCE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE, MANY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS THESE BENEFITS
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. THESE
BUSINESSES OFFER THE SAME
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES AS OTHERS
CERTIFIED BUSINESSES. HOWEVER,
SOME SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS MAY
NOT HAVE PROOF OF LAWFUL STATUS
IN THIS COUNTRY. Kò. EVEN WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ISSUED AN EMPLOYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER, THIS
PREVENTS THEM FROM ACCESSING THE
BENEFITS OF SMALL BUSINESS
CERTIFICATION AND RESTRICTS
THEIR ABILITY TO EXPAND AND TO
CONTINUE TO HELP THE STATE'S
ECONOMY GROW. ASSEMBLY BILL 2005
43 SIMPLY STATES THAT ELIGIBLE
SMALL BUSINESSES MAY BE
CERTIFIED REGARDLESS OF THEIR
CITIZENSHIP OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS OF ITS OWNER. FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW ALREADY AUTHORIZES
THESE BUSINESS OWNERS TO BE IN
BUSINESS. IT IS TIME FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT THESE BUSINESS
OWNERS CAN THRIVE AND EXPAND.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 2543. FIRST IS
ALEJANDRO GUILLEN. WITH
IMMIGRANTS RISING AND SECOND IS
JEANETTE ESPARZA WITH
ENTREPRENEUR. ALL RIGHT. EACH
SPEAKER HAS TWO MINUTES. AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE,
PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ALEJANDRO
GUILLEN. I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT IMMIGRANTS RISING. I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS IMMIGRANT IMMIGRANTS
RISING. WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT FOR
AB 2543, IMMIGRANTS RISING.
ESTABLISHED IN 2006, HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO EMPOWERING UNDOCU
POINTED PEOPLE AND TO ACHIEVE
THEIR EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES REYES ASPIRATIONS.
WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS, EVERYONE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO THRIVE THROUGH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. OVER THE PAST
DECADE, WE'VE DEVELOPED PROGRAMS
AND RESOURCES TO EDUCATE AND
EMPOWER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ABOUT ENTREPRENEURSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. OUR EFFORTS HAVE
YIELDED TANGIBLE RESULTS. WE
WERE HONORED TO HAVE RECEIVED,
$7.4 MILLION THROUGH THE STATE'S
SEED INITIATIVE, WHICH WE
DISTRIBUTED TO NEARLY 1000
IMMIGRANT ENTREPRENEURS
STATEWIDE. THE INVESTMENT HAS
ENABLED INDIVIDUALS TO CLIMB THE
ECONOMIC LADDER AND CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. RESEARCH UNDERSCORES
THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE MORE
INCLINED TOWARDS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. THROUGH OUR
WORK, WE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND HOW
ENTREPRENEURSHIP SERVES AS A
LIFELINE, PARTICULARLY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FACING
EMPLOYMENT LIMITATIONS POST
GRADUATION. AB 2543 ALIGNS WITH
OUR MISSION AND VALUES BY
EXPANDING BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES. THE INDIVIDUALS
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL NOT ONLY
FOSTERS ECONOMIC GROWTH, BUT
ALSO PROMOTES INCLUSIVITY AND
EQUITY WITHIN OUR STATE. IN
CONCLUSION, WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 2543. LET'S ENSURE
THAT ALL INDIVIDUALS, REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS, HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
PROSPERITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JEANETTE
ESPARZA, AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE THE PASSING OF AB 2543.
I AM THE PROUD OWNER OF
RESIDENTIAL CLEANING SERVICES,
WHICH I ESTABLISHED TWO YEARS
AGO. THROUGH DEDICATION, MY
BUSINESS HAS FLOURISHED, NOW
SERVING A TOTAL OF 60 REGULAR
CLIENTS, ACCOMMODATING ANOTHER
70 CLIENTS MONTHLY. THESE ARE
SIX HAS EMPOWERED ME TO PROVIDE
ME FOR MY FAMILY AND CONTRIBUTE
TO MY COMMUNITY. DURING THE
PANDEMIC, I FOUND MYSELF LAID
OFF FROM A STABLE JOB AFTER
DEDICATING 13 YEARS OF MY LIFE
TO IT. THAT DIDN'T STOP ME. I
SEIZED THE OPPORTUNITY AND
STARTED MY BUSINESS. THAT SEED
GRANT PROVIDE ME, PROVIDED BY
IMMIGRANT RACING, WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING ME WITH
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND
KNOWLEDGE TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE DIFFICULTIES. TODAY, I
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO OTHERS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
I ALSO ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
EXPANDING MY BUSINESS OPERATIONS
TO INCLUDE COMMERCIAL CLEANING
SERVICES. I'M EXCITED TO OFFER
MY SERVICES TO GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES. THIS HELPS CREATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT BENEFITS
EVERYONE. IT MAKES OUR SOCIETY
BETTER. AB 2543 IS NOT JUST A
BILL, IT'S A PATHWAY TO
INCLUSIVITY AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT. TO INDIVIDUALS LIKE
MYSELF WHO MAY BE UNDOCUMENTED.
BY GRANTING ACCESS TO A STATE
CERTIFICATION TO FOR ALL
RECEIVING ENTREPRENEURS. IN
CONCLUSION, I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 2543. IT WILL HELP
PEOPLE LIKE ME TO THRIVE AND
ENSURE WE CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA PROSPERITY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND
CONGRATULATIONS FOR SEIZING THE
DAY, ANYBODY ELSE HERE THAT
WANTS TO ADD ME TO TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE
ANY, ANYBODY WANTING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANKS FOR
JOINING US. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELL, I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS, BUT ALWAYS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS EFFORTS.
AND SO JUST CAME ON THE TAIL END
OF HER TESTIMONY. BUT THANK YOU.
AND I'VE BEEN, YOU KNOW, READING
AND CONSIDERING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO BE A
COAUTHOR. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. AND THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK. SO IS
THAT A IS THAT A MOTION? TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. OKAY. VERY GOOD.
ANYBODY ELSE I'LL JUST MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT, I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. I RECENTLY MET WITH,
THE SOUTH MODESTO BUSINESS
UNITED COMMUNITY, WHICH IS A, A
GROUP OF ENTREPRENEURS, SOME
FIRST YEAR, SECOND YEAR
IMMIGRANTS. AND THE NUMBER ONE
QUESTION WAS, WHAT IS THE STATE
DOING FOR BUSINESS OWNERS? WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TO INVEST IN,
DIVERSE CULTURAL BUSINESSES? AND
SO I THINK YOUR BILL REALLY
SPEAKS TO THAT, AND THANK YOU
FOR LEADING ON THIS. AND IF
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COAUTHOR, I WOULD LOVE TO BE ON
THAT AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP, AND THIS IS WHAT I
REALLY LIKE ABOUT THE BILL,
BECAUSE IT BRINGS PEOPLE OUT
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING, IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICT, IN
OUR STATE THAT ACTUALLY, AS YOU
JUST SAID, THEY'VE REGISTERED
WITH THE IRS, THEY'VE THEY'VE
GOTTEN THEIR BUSINESS LICENSES
AND SO ON. AND IT'S JUST THAT
PATHWAY. I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
INCENTIVE TO GET MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THE PATHWAY TO
DO IT CORRECTLY. AND BECOME
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO I WISH YOU WELL WITH THE
BILL, AND I WILL SUPPORT IT. AND
WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION. THANK
YOU. YOUR STREAK IS BROKEN,
SENATOR ARCHULETA. WITH THAT,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR.
VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS, I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
WITNESS TODAY WHO SAID THIS IS A
PATHWAY TO INCLUSIVE VIÆT AND
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT FOR TOO
MANY OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL THAT THEY NEED TO
FLOURISH. BY BEING ABLE TO PASS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2543 AND HAVING
THEIR SMALL BUSINESS CERTIFIED
WITH THE STATE, WE'RE BETTER
ABLE TO CREATE THAT PATHWAY AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THRIVING IN OUR
STATE AND MOVING OUR ECONOMY
FORWARD WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU SIR. AGAIN, WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR RUBIO. AS
YOU CAN SEE, WE CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP ONCE WE DO. I SEE NO
OTHER AUTHORS IN THE ROOM. Ó
ASSEMBLYWOMAN ORTEGA, I'M SORRY.
COME ON IN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
PLEASE. SO COMING UP NEXT,
AGAIN, OUT OF FILE ORDER. FILE
ITEM THREE AB 2068 BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN ORTEGA. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS TO THE LABOR
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT SHE
SETTLED. SO GO AHEAD AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE,
BEGIN. THANK YOU, SENATOR AND
CHAIR AND SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2068 TODAY, AB 2068 WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THAT
CONTRACT THE PUBLIC AND CUSTOMER
CALL CENTER SERVICES OUT OF
STATE TO PROVIDE A FULL LIST OF
THESE CONTRACTS. IN RECENT
YEARS, THERE HAVE BEEN
INDICATIONS THAT MANY CALIFORNIA
CALL CENTER LOCATED IN OTHER
STATES, EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
PAID EXCLUSIVELY BY CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. AB 2068 WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE TO GATHER A
MASTER LIST OF ALL OUT OF STATE
CALL CENTER CONTRACTS THAT THE
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
HAVE SIGNED, THE COST TO
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS, AND THE
NUMBER OF TYPES OF JOBS FOUND IN
OTHER STATES. I HAVE A WITNESS
WITH ME IN SUPPORT. GREAT SIR.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GREAT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. IGNACIO
HERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
, DISTRICT NINE, WHICH
ENCOMPASSES CALIFORNIA, NEVADA
AND HAWAII. WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. IN RECENT YEARS,
WE'VE SEEN CALL CENTER JOBS MOVE
OUT OF CALIFORNIA OVERSEAS INTO
OTHER STATES, BOTH IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND ALSO THE
PUBLIC SECTOR, STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS ARE INCREASINGLY
RELYING ON THESE OUT OF STATE ON
VENDORS WHO ARE MOVING THESE
CALL CENTERS OUT OF STATE, WHERE
WE'RE SEEING JOBS BEING LOST
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE
JOBS THAT ARE PATHWAYS TO MIDDLE
CLASS. THEY ARE CAREERS FOR LOTS
OF FOLKS. AND WE WANT TO FIND A
WAY TO BRING THESE JOBS BACK.
ONE OF THE BARRIERS IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION AS TO
WHICH STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS ARE IN FACT,
CONTRACTING, AND HOW MANY JOBS
ARE BEING SENT OUT OF STATE.
WE'VE ASKED FOR THIS INFORMATION
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GATHER
THAT EARLIER THIS YEAR, THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED A BILL TO
EXPAND THE EXISTING MANDATE THAT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CALL CENTERS
REMAIN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NHÀ
WE CANNOT CRAFT A BILL TO EXPAND
THAT LAW AND IDENTIFY WHICH
DEPARTMENT AND AGENCIES SHOULD
KEEP THEIR CALL CENTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA UNTIL WE HAVE THIS
INFORMATION. SO WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR. ANYONE ELSE IN IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO ADD ME TO SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WE'LL MOVE TO. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? SEEING
NONE. PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS? COMMENTS?
CONCERNS THAT MEANS YOU'RE GOOD.
NO. YEAH. Ó COMMENTS. I'M GOING
TO GO WITH YOU FIRST. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE. OH AND TWO NOW. YEAH.
THANK YOU. I MEAN, THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT I'VE SORT
OF BEEN EXPLORING BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND YET OUR STATE
AGENCIES ARE USING OUTSIDE, YOU
KNOW, EMPLOYEES, WHICH I THINK
IT'S JUST A TRAVESTY BECAUSE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
OUR JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO, I MEAN,
I ALSO KNOW THAT THE QUALITY OF
INTERACTION DIMINISHES. YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, IT
HAPPENS MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THAT
YOU CALL AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
JUST FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
COMMUNICATE BECAUSE YOU JUST
KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT, YOU KNOW,
NOT ONLY FROM FROM OUR STATE,
BUT OUT OF THE COUNTRY
SOMETIMES. AND SO IT'S A GREAT
BILL. THANK YOU. AND THIS IS
ANOTHER BILL THAT I'VE ALREADY,
YOU KNOW, SHARED WITH YOUR
OFFICE THAT I WANT TO COAUTHOR
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEND A
MESSAGE THAT WE VALUE OUR JOBS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND IF IT'S
A STATE AGENCY, IT HAS MORE
POWER FOR US TO SAY, SEND A LOUD
MESSAGE THAT WE BELIEVE IN THE
WORKERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. AND OF
COURSE, OUR SPEAKER. YOU KNOW,
WE ARE, REALIZING MORE AND MORE
THAT BUSINESSES NEED TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR WORKFORCE NEEDS
TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA. AND I'VE
ENCOURAGED IT, AND I'VE SAID IT
PUBLICLY THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
GOOD HANDLE ON EXACTLY WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE. AND I THINK THIS
BILL WILL DO THAT. IT WILL SHOW
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS THAT
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND SHOW
EVERY AGENCY WHAT IS BEING
DIVERTED OUTSIDE THE STATE AND
WHY. SO IN THE INTERIM, WE CAN
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT IT. AND WE
TALKED ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES,
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW MANY
BUSINESSES WE'RE LOSING. SO THIS
IS A GOOD WAY TO DO IT. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO BE A COAUTHOR. SO
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, AND I
MAKE THE MOTION AT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
GOOD ALVARADO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, ASSEMBLYWOMAN ORTEGA, I, I
ENJOY YOUR BILLS BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT YOU TAKE A VERY DIRECT,
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
PROTECTING WORKERS. AND THIS
BILL, YOU KNOW, SEEMS LIKE WE
SHOULDN'T NEED IT. IT SEEMS LIKE
WE SHOULD JUST BE ABLE TO ASK
THE QUESTION AND GET THAT DATA
OUT, SO I I'M SORRY THAT THE
BUREAUCRACY IN OUR STATE HAS
GOTTEN TO BE SO COMPLEX THAT WE
CANNOT ACCOUNT FOR HOW WE TREAT
OUR WORKERS. SO THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO CHAMPION OUR
WORKFORCE, THIS IS A GREAT BILL,
I'LL SAY ONE OF MY VERY FIRST
JOBS WAS, CALLING FOR NEWSPAPERS
FOR, THE PRESS DEMOCRAT. AND I
REMEMBER THAT JUST THAT
INTERACTION AND CUSTOMER
SERVICE, YOU KNOW, OPENED THE
DOORS TO ME, SPEAKING PUBLICLY
AND JUST BEING ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH PEOPLE. SO, I MEAN, I, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THOSE ENTRY
LEVEL JOBS THAT KIND OF BRING US
AWAY FROM OUR PHONES AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND I TO REAL PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. AND I THINK THERE IS
ALREADY A MOTION. SO YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. CONTINUING
DOWN THE LINE, SENATOR OCHOA
BOGH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, GOOD
MORNING. MEMBER ORTEGA, GRATEFUL
TO SEE YOU HERE THIS MORNING. SO
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SO
I UNDERSTAND THE END RESULT FOR
THIS REQUEST FOR THE STUDY IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE BRING THESE JOBS
BACK. BUT I DO WANT TO, A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS FOR CLARIFICATION.
AND FOR THE RECORD, ONE, MANY OF
THESE STATE AGENCIES HAVE TO BID
THESE JOBS, RIGHT. MOST OF THESE
CONTRACTS AND HAVE TO BE, PUT
OUT TO BID BEFORE THESE
CONTRACTS ARE ACTUALLY SIGNED.
RIGHT. I UNDERSTAND. YES, YES.
OKAY. SO, AND IT'S ONE OF THE
AND I WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE FACT THAT, IF THESE
COMPANIES AND I'M ASSUMING FOR
THE RECORD, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC, COMPANIES THAT WERE
CONTRACTING WITH. YES. YEAH.
YEAH. PLEASE. THANK YOU, IF I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION, THIS
BILL IS JUST COVERING CONTRACTS
AT THE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS HAVE, FOR CALL
CENTER SERVICES. SO. AND THE
CALL CENTERS ARE BOTH PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC. I THINK THEY WOULD
JUST BE PRIVATE COMPANIES. SO
JUST PRIVATE COMPANIES. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE, REQUESTING THE
INFORMATION ON THESE CONTRACTS
THAT IMPACT PRIVATE COMPANIES,
AND I AND I JUST WANT TO SAY SO
PRIVATE COMPANIES, LOWEST BIDDER
, RIGHT. THAT NORMALLY THE STATE
ACQUIRES, IF I MAY JUST 15
SECONDS EXPAND ON THAT IN OUR
MEETINGS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS, I SHOULD GIVE SOME
CONTEXT. WE'VE ACTUALLY RUN
BILLS IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS TO BRING TRY TO BRING
THESE JOBS BACK. SO WE'VE MET
WITH STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AND A NUMBER OF
STATE PROGRAMS WHO HAVE BEEN
FORTHCOMING AND BEEN ABLE TO
SHARE WITH US, HOW THEY GO ABOUT
ENTERING THESE CONTRACTS AND HOW
MORE OR LESS HOW MANY JOBS THAT
THEY HAVE. JUST A LOT OF
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES HAVE
NOT SHARED THAT. AND FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT LOW COST
IS ONE FACTOR, BUT NOT THE ONLY
FACTOR THAT IS CONSIDERED IN
ENTERING INTO THESE CONTRACTS.
WE HAVE ASKED WHETHER OR NOT
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE PART
OF THAT, THEY ARE TYPICALLY NOT
PART OF THAT. I CAN SAY JUST
REAL QUICKLY, THERE'S TO BE KIND
OF A GENERAL CONTRACTING
PRINCIPLE IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE CAL NET, PROGRAM. IF I
REMEMBER, IF I'M REMEMBERING THE
NAME CORRECTLY, WHICH USED TO
REQUIRE THAT CONTRACTS FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR CALL
CENTERS, AND TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICES BE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA, THE WORK HAD TO BE
IN CALIFORNIA. THOSE PROVISIONS
ARE NO LONGER PART OF THE CAL
NET CONTRACTS. SO THIS IS A
NEWER PHENOMENON. AND THE
BIDDING IS KIND OF A NEWER
PHENOMENON AS WELL. BUT THAT'S
YOU KNOW, SO THERE ARE MANY
FACTORS THAT GO INTO IT. AND
JUST RIGHT NOW, LOCATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONE OF THOSE
FACTORS THAT'S CONSIDERED. SO IN
IN DETERMINING THE, THE NEW
CRITERIA OF REQUIRING THE LOWEST
BIDDER OR THE LOWEST COST TO THE
STATE, IT ACTUALLY IMPACTS THE
COST OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE. RIGHT. BUT
WELL, RIGHT NOW THIS BILL IS
JUST COLLECTING THE DATA, THIS
DATA. BUT I'M JUST BUT THE BUT
BUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THOUGH IS, IS, IS ALL OF
THESE FACTORS ACTUALLY COME INTO
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT WE
LOSE THESE COMPANIES OR THESE
CONTRACTS TO OUTSIDE BIDDERS OUT
OF CALIFORNIA? THE POINT THAT
I'M TRYING TO GET IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE BILL IS
TRYING TO GET GET AT, BUT I'M
TRYING TO POINT TO THE POINT TO
THE FACT THAT MANY OF THE TIMES
WE'RE LOSING BUSINESSES TO
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
IT'S SO COSTLY TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO OUR COMPANIES
MOVE OUT OF STATE BECAUSE IT'S
MORE COST EFFECTIVE, OTHERWISE
THEY WOULD BE HERE, AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE'RE
GOING. SO IT'S ALMOST A
BAND-AID. IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
FIXING THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM,
WHICH IS WE HAVE TO LOWER THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THESE BUSINESSES
CAN STAY HERE IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO CONTRACT WITH THEM
WITH MORE CALIFORNIANS, BECAUSE
I THINK AS A STATE, I THINK IN
GENERAL, IF WE COULD, WE WOULD
WANT TO AWARD OUR CONTRACTS TO
STATE OWNED BUSINESSES. I KNOW
THAT I HAD A BILL A COUPLE OF
YEARS BACK THAT WOULD
PRIORITIZE, YOU KNOW, COMPANIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WHEN WE'RE
DETERMINING, YOU KNOW, WHO DO WE
GIVE THE CONTRACTS OUT TO, SO I,
I'M ABSOLUTELY WITH YOU ON THAT
END, BUT IT DOES. WE DO HAVE TO
GET TO THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM
AS TO WHY WE'RE LOSING THESE
CONTRACTS TO OUTSIDE AND WHY
THESE JOBS ARE GOING TO OUT OF
STATE, COMPANIES AND IMPACTING
OUR WORKFORCE. SO THAT'S THE
POINT THAT I'M GATHERING. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT WE HAVE TO GO FURTHER ON
THIS. IT HAS TO WE HAVE TO WORK
ON THE ON THE BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
CAN HAVE THESE COMPANIES STAY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
FOR THE QUESTIONS AND THE
COMMENTS AND ALWAYS APPRECIATE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
GOING FORWARD. I CAN SAY THAT
WHEN WE GET THIS DATA, WE WILL
BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY DO A NUMBERS
CRUNCH AND SEE IF IT ACTUALLY IS
CHEAPER IN OTHER STATES OR NOT.
RIGHT NOW, WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS TO COMPARE IT. BUT THAT
IS SOMETHING WE'LL LOOK AT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION. I'LL MAKE A QUICK
CLOSING COMMENT AND THEN YOU MAY
CLOSE. I'M SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY FOR TWO REASONS. ONE, I'VE
HAD SIMILAR EXPERIENCES TO
SENATOR RUBIO WHERE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH SOMEBODY WHO
OVERSEAS HIS NAME IS BOB, BUT
IT'S NOT BOB, AND YOU CAN'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND THEM. THAT'S ONE. AND
NUMBER TWO, WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE THREE CO-EQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT AND WHEN WE AND WE
HAVE OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY,
AT LEAST ACCORDING TO THE STATE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH I DON'T
THINK WE DO ENOUGH OF PERSONALLY
, AND SO WHEN WE ASK FOR
INFORMATION, THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH SHOULD GIVE IT TO US. AND
AGAIN, I, I PREFER PEOPLE IF
IT'S TAXPAYER MONEY, I PREFER TO
THOSE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING MONEY
TO CALIFORNIANS. SO THAT'S MY
POSITION. SUPPORT YOU TODAY. AND
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. I THINK YOU
ALL DID THE CLOSING FOR ME,
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY I'M RUNNING
THIS BILL, INCLUDING, THE
SENATOR, YOU KNOW, REGARDS TO
DATA AND, YOU KNOW, GOING
FURTHER, IT'S HARD TO GO FURTHER
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. THÀNH WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE DON'T YET
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WHEN WE DO,
WE WILL MAKE WE WILL BRING THAT
UP IN. THE MOTION WAS MADE BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND OUR ESTEEMED
LEADERS BACK SO I WILL RETURN
THE GAVEL TO YOU, SIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR. WE'LL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE,
AB 2983. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT WAS FUN. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
DODD AND SENATORS. FIRST, LET ME
THANK CHAIR DODD AND STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR WORK AND ATTENTION ON
THIS BILL. I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. AB 2983
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PROGRAM BOARD WHEN
EVALUATING MITIGATION PROJECTS
OR PROPOSALS TO ASSESS THE
EXTENT SUCH WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PROJECTS WOULD INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF WILDFIRE
INSURANCE POLICIES.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE BE ADDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PROGRAM BOARD BY JULY 1ST OF
NEXT YEAR TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION. CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT AFFORD A DISJOINTED
RESPONSE TO THE UNPRECEDENTED
RISK WE FACE FROM CLIMATE DRIVEN
FIRES AND WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACES IN THE LAST TWO
FISCAL YEARS ALONE, CAL OES HAS
RECEIVED ALMOST $800 MILLION IN
FEDERAL HAZARD MITIGATION
FUNDING TO BUY DOWN RISK ACROSS
THE STATE. SIMULTANEOUSLY,
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE CRISIS HAS
WORSENED, WITH HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS FORCED
TO OBTAIN INSURANCE THROUGH THE
FAIR PLAN, WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO
BE AN INSURER OF LAST RESORT.
THIS BILL ENSURES THERE IS
MEANINGFUL COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION EXPERTS
AND THE INSURANCE POLICY
REGULATORS SO THAT OUR FEDERAL
AND STATE MITIGATION INVESTMENTS
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT COMMUNITIES
AND MAKE WILDFIRE INSURANCE MORE
AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DEBORAH CARLTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS. AYE. DEBORAH FORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION, THIS BILL
IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT STEP
TO HELPING US FIND WAYS TO LOWER
OUR INSURANCE. OUR FOLKS HAVE
DONE A LOT OF HARDENING OF THEIR
AROUND THEIR BUILDINGS, BUT
WE'RE STILL SEEING INCREASES IN
INSURANCE 20, 30, SOMETIMES 50.
AND I HATE TO SAY IT, BUT THAT'S
IN THE BEST CASE SCENARIO. SOME
ARE JUST HAVING THEIR INSURANCE
CANCELED ALTOGETHER. AND THIS IS
NOT JUST IN THE FIRE ZONES. THIS
IS ALL THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA,
AND ESPECIALLY FOR RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS IN CITIES. THEY
CANNOT INCREASE THE RENT, SO
THEY CANNOT RECOUP THESE COSTS.
THE SMALLER OWNERS ARE CHOOSING
TO EXIT THE MARKET AND SELL TO
OWNER OCCUPANCY. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY AT
THE INSURANCE RATES THAT THEY'RE
BEING REQUIRED TO PAY. SO WITH
THIS, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE'LL
TAKE THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS. DO ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, IF I MAY,
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU.
WELCOME BACK. I HOPE YOU'RE
FEELING BETTER, GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. I KNOW THAT YOU
WORK A LOT ON, JUST EMERGENCY
SERVICES, WHICH IS, YOU KNOW,
WHAT YOU DO BACK HOME AS WELL AS
AN EMT. BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
VERY, ENTHUSIASTIC THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT. I THINK WHAT YOU
SAID, AND IT'S KEY THAT
MEANINGFUL COLLABORATION, YOU
KNOW, AS CHAIR OF THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE, I KNOW THAT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE, ESPECIALLY FOR, YOU
KNOW, CONDOS AND APARTMENTS, AND
YOU KNOW, IN FACT, THERE'S BEEN
TIMES WHERE WE'RE TOLD THAT
PEOPLE ARE STOP BUILDING, CONDOS
AND AFFORDABLE, YOU KNOW,
APARTMENTS BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF INSURANCE. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THAT EVERYONE IS
AT THE TABLE HAVING THAT
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION. I KNOW
THAT, WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
A PLAN TO ENSURE THAT WE FIGURE
OUT THE INSURANCE CRISIS, BUT
THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR JUST, YOU
KNOW, GETTING EVERYONE TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING ON THAT, YOU KNOW,
THAT DISCUSSION. AND SO THANK
YOU. AND, YOU KNOW, I DO WANT TO
BE A COAUTHOR TO THIS BILL. AND
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT,
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT SOMETIMES
I THINK, THERE'S A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING THE CONNECTIVITY
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, BUILDING
HOMES AND INSURANCE. RIGHT. BUT
IF YOU CAN'T GET INSURANCE, SOME
OF OUR BUILDERS ARE THEY STOP
BUILDING AND WE'RE IN CALIFORNIA
MOVING TOWARDS BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WELL, IF WE
ARE NOT PROVIDING THE INSURANCE,
IT CURVES OUR ABILITY TO MEET
OUR GOALS. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND I WILL MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. I'LL ADD CHEN AS
COAUTHOR. ANYBODY ELSE? SENATOR
WILK, I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
SENATOR RUBIO, AND I ALSO TOO
WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
COAUTHOR WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU. OKAY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE, AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS. YES, CHAIRMAN. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DO WE HAVE
A MOTION? WAS THAT SENATOR, WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET. OF
COURSE, SO WITH THAT, WHEN WE
GET OUR QUORUM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILL BE VOTING ON THIS.
APPRECIATE YOU COMING THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SIR. THANK YOU. I AM GOING TO
CALL OUT AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
SENATOR ASHBY, SENATOR BRADFORD,
SENATOR GLAZER, SENATOR JONES,
SENATOR NGUYEN, SENATOR PADILLA,
AND SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
SENATOR SATO, WE NEED TWO FOR A
QUORUM. I WISH YOU WOULD COME
DOWN AND CHECK IN AND LET'S GET
A QUORUM SO WE CAN MOVE THIS
ALONG. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR? FOR THE RECORD, YOU HAD
TO NAVIGATE A THREE CAR ACCIDENT
ON THE WAY IN FROM THE DISTRICT
THIS MORNING. WHICH IS WHY
YOU'RE LATE. AND YET YOU WERE
ABLE TO BE HERE, AND ALL THESE
OTHER PEOPLE ARE AWOL. I'M IN
COMPLETE AGREEMENT, SENATOR.
OKAY, WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 14. THAT'S AB 3069
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES. YEAH.
YOU'RE SPECIAL. YOU GET IN THERE
. NO, NO. OH, HERE WE GO. IT'S
SO PROFESSIONAL IN HERE. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY. GOOD MORNING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HOW ARE YOU
TODAY. REALLY GOOD. GOOD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
SENATORS, TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3069. I FIRST WANT TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS MEASURE.
COME TIED HOUSE LAWS GENERALLY
PROHIBIT A MANUFACTURER FROM
PAYING FOR ADVERTISING SPACE AT
ANY FACILITY WHERE THE FACILITY
IS LICENSED TO SELL ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. HOWEVER IN RECENT
LEGISLATIVE YEARS, THE STATE HAS
MADE EXCEPTIONS TO THIS RULE FOR
LARGE STADIUMS AND ENTERTAINMENT
VENUES. AB 3069 IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE TO ALLOW FOR AN
EXEMPTION TO THIS RULE FOR THE
NEW FRONTWAVE ARENA THAT IS
OPENING UP IN OCEANSIDE,
CALIFORNIA. SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS
HAVE BEEN GIVEN FOR ARENAS LIKE
SOFI STADIUM AND VARIOUS
SPORTING ARENAS LIKE PETCO PARK.
THE FRONTWAVE ARENA IS THE FIRST
LARGE MULTI-PURPOSE
ENTERTAINMENT VENUE IN NORTH
COUNTY AREA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND WILL BE A HUGE ECONOMIC BOON
FOR THE AREA, WITH ME HERE
TODAY, JUST IN CASE THERE ARE
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE ARENA AND NEED FOR THE BILL
IS BILL MAHER, SENATORS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT? ARE YOU IN SUPPORT?
HE'S MY WITNESS. TECHNICAL OR
TECHNICAL? OKAY. YEAH. ANYBODY
ELSE? I HOPE HE SUPPORTS IT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? OAN.
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK SOON. I
WAS GOING TO. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU. I YOU KNOW, I JUST
RESPECTFULLY TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WE DO THIS FOR VENUES
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA. I THINK
YOUR DISTRICT DESERVES THE SAME
COURTESY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN READY.
SENATOR WILK, WE'RE DOING IT FOR
THE FOR THE HOLLYWOOD CEMETERY
SO WE CAN DO IT FOR 5000 SEAT
ARENA. SO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT.
SENATOR ROTH, DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO ADD? NO,
NO, I'M JUST WAITING FOR A
QUORUM. ME TOO. OKAY. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS? SO THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM? OBVIOUSLY. SO WE'LL
GET TO THIS BILL AS SOON AS WE
DO. THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
KNOW, SHE DID IT. SHE DID IT.
BEAUTIFUL. THANK YOU. WITHOUT
EVEN BEING ASKED. THAT'S
PROFESSIONAL OKAY. SO I'M GOING
TO DO IT AGAIN, SENATOR ASHBY,
SENATOR BRADFORD, SENATOR
GLAZER, SENATOR NGUYEN. SENATOR
JONES, SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. SENATOR. SATO WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET TWO OF YOU
DOWN HERE SO THAT WE CAN DO THE
BUSINESS OF THE STATE. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL MOUNT. NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THAT'S AB
2069. GALLAGHER. SAY YOUR
BIRTHDAY GIFT FOR MY WIFE. YEAH,
YEAH. NICE MORNING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN, IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU THIS MORNING TO PRESENT
AB 2069, A BILL THAT AIMS TO
ADDRESS AN EXISTING DISPARITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ALCOHOL SALE
REGULATIONS. AB 2069 SEEKS TO
RECTIFY A DISCREPANCY IN CURRENT
LAW REGARDING THE SALE OF
DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED SOJU AND
SOJU BY ON SALE BEER AND WINE
LICENSE HOLDERS. CURRENTLY,
THESE LICENSES TYPICALLY
RESTAURANTS AND TAVERNS, ARE
ALLOWED TO SELL IMPORTED SOJU
AND SOJU ALONGSIDE WINE.
HOWEVER, THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM SELLING DOMESTICALLY
PRODUCED SOJU AND SOJU DESPITE
MEETING THE SAME REGULATORY
STANDARDS AS THEIR IMPORTED
COUNTERPARTS. THIS IMBALANCE
PLACES CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS AT A
SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGE AND
UNDERMINES ECONOMIC FAIRNESS IN
THE INDUSTRY. AB 2069 WOULD
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD BY
ALLOWING ON SALE LICENSEES TO
SELL THE DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED
SOJU AND SOJU, THEREBY
SUPPORTING LOCAL DISTILLERIES.
CALIFORNIA FOR BUSINESSES,
CALIFORNIA LOCAL DISTILLERIES
AND ENCOURAGE THE UTILIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA SOURCED INGREDIENTS
AS WELL. SO I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 2069 AND
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROMOTING ECONOMIC EQUITY AND
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS CHRIS
KOENIG, OWNER OF THE GOLDEN
BEAVER DISTILLERY, AND MATT
WEISS WITH DC BEVERAGE. GOOD
MORNING. MORNING, SENATORS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. I'M A DISTILLER AND
OWNER. ONE OF THE PARTNERS IN
GOLDEN BEAVER DISTILLERY OUT OF
CHICO, CALIFORNIA, AND WE
PRODUCE SOJU. WE'RE ONE OF THE
FIVE DISTILLERIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT ACTUALLY PRODUCES
100% RICE BASED SPIRITS.
EVERYTHING FROM WHISKEY THROUGH,
GIN AND VODKA AND SOJU, OUR
SPIRITS HAVE WON AWARDS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS
INTERNATIONAL COMPETITIONS. YET
MY COMPANY CANNOT SELL TO BEER
AND WINE LICENSES WHERE
IMPORTERS CAN. AND IT IS NOT
FAIR TO MY EMPLOYEES. IT'S NOT
FAIR TO MY VENDORS WHO SUPPLY US
LOCALLY GROWN CALIFORNIA RICE.
AND IT'S JUST NOT. IT'S JUST NOT
AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD FOR MY
COMPANY. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ALLOW US TO HAVE FREE MARKET
ACCESS AS OUR FOREIGN
COMPETITORS HAVE IN THIS IN OUR
OWN STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS MATTHEW WEISS. I OPERATE DC
BEVERAGE, WHICH IS A SMALL
DISTRIBUTOR OF, COMPLETELY
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLERS. AND
IF I WANT TO GO OUT AND CAPTURE
THE SOJU AND SOJU MARKET, I HAVE
TWO CHOICES. MY FIRST CHOICE IS
I CAN GO THROUGH THE ARDUOUS,
COMPLICATED, AND EXPENSIVE
PROCESS OF IMPORTING A KOREAN
SOJU OR I COULD DRIVE UP THE I-5
OR DOWN THE 101 ABOUT AN HOUR
AND PICK UP A LOCALLY PRODUCED
CALIFORNIA FARMED SOJU. THE
CHOICE SEEMS SIMPLE, HOWEVER,
THE KOREAN SOJU HAS A MAJOR
ADVANTAGE OVER THE LOCAL SOJU,
AND THAT IT CAN BE SOLD IN FAR
MORE ACCOUNTS, BASED ON THE WAY
THAT THE LAW IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN, AND SO WE WOULD ASK
THAT WE PUT THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCERS ON THE SAME LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD AS THE KOREAN
PRODUCERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT SPEAKER, PLEASE.
THESE ARE JUST ME TWOS. NOW
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS CARLOS GUTIERREZ HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT?
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION FOR MEMBERS. ANYBODY
HAVE ANYTHING, SENATOR RUBIO?
WELL, I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
SAY I THINK THIS SPEAKS TO ALSO
THE PREVIOUS BILL WE DISCUSSED
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT. AND THIS IS CALIFORNIA
PRODUCED. ARCHULETA, YOU KNOW,
THE NEW PRODUCT ESPECIALLY, YOU
KNOW, IT'S GOING TO PRODUCE JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE KEEP IT IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. SO I APPRECIATE WHEN
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR THESE
DISCREPANCIES. AND AS
CALIFORNIANS, WE NEED TO SEND A
LOUD MESSAGE THAT WE CARE ABOUT
OUR JOBS HERE AND OUR BUSINESSES
HERE OVER THOSE THAT ARE
OUTSIDE. SO I'LL MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK. HOW DO YOU EVEN
KNOW HOW THIS HAPPENED? DO I
KNOW HOW IT HAPPENED? YEAH. THE
DISCREPANCY, WELL, I CAN'T
REMEMBER HOW LONG AGO, BUT,
KOREAN IMPORTERS OF SOJU,
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO REGULATE
AS BEER AND WINE AS OPPOSED TO
HARD LIQUOR, SO THAT IT COULD BE
SOLD IN, RESTAURANTS THAT ONLY
HAD A BEER AND WINE LICENSE. NOW
I DON'T THINK THERE'S
NECESSARILY ANYTHING WRONG WITH
THAT. YOU KNOW, AND THAT BECAUSE
THAT TRADITIONALLY THAT'S A
BEVERAGE THAT'S BEEN MORE OF
LIKE A BEER AND WINE, BUT TO NOT
TREAT OUR CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS
AND DISTILLERS IN THE SAME WAY.
AND BE ABLE TO SELL THEIR
PRODUCT TO BEER AND WINE
DISTILLERS, IS THE DISCREPANCY
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO, CLOSE,
SIR, HOW DID YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DO? HE DID GREAT. OKAY.
THE GENESIS OF THIS CAME OUT OF
THE LA RIOTS. IT WAS, TO, THE
KOREAN COMMUNITY, POST RIOTS,
APPROACHED THE STATE TO ALLOW
SOJU TO BE SERVED IN, KOREAN
BARBECUE AND SUSHI BARS. AND
THAT'S HOW IT DEVELOPED. AND
THAT WAS LONG BEFORE WE HAD A
CRAFT DISTILLERS MARKET. SO WE
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF IT.
WE, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY AGREE
WITH THE HISTORY. WE'D JUST LIKE
TO GET IT CORRECTED AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
AGAIN, YOU WERE THREE YEARS OLD
IN 1992. SO I GUESS I SHOULDN'T
EXPECT YOU TO KNOW THAT. SO
YOU'RE FORGIVEN. SO I WOULD HAVE
BEEN 11. BUT BUT STILL PRETTY
YOUNG. YOU'RE SO YOUNG LOOKING.
YOU LOOK SUPPORT THE BILL.
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS, I THINK
WHAT YOU OUGHT TO DO BEFORE THIS
THING HITS THE FLOOR IS YOU
SHOULD. BECAUSE I'VE NEVER HAD
IT. YOU SHOULD HAVE A TASTING IN
YOUR OFFICE FOR ALL THE
SENATORS. SO WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON BECAUSE I BELIEVED IN
AN INFORMED SENATE WITH THAT.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. I DON'T WANT TO BE
ACCUSED OF TRYING TO GET VOTES
WITH LIQUOR, YEAH. COME ON. BUT
BUT I THINK FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES, EVERYBODY SHOULD TRY
IT OUT. IT'S. YEAH, IT IS A VERY
GOOD BEVERAGE. WELL CAN I ADD
SOMETHING TO THAT REAL QUICKLY?
AND I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR. AND
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT LIKE THE
ALCOHOL, BUT YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
LIKE THE RICE GROWERS AND ALL
THESE OTHER BUSINESSES THAT
BENEFIT FROM, FROM SUPPORTING
THIS PRODUCT. SO MAKE SURE IT'S
NOT ABOUT ALCOHOL. BUT ALL THE
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT BENEFIT AS
WELL. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THESE
DISCLAIMERS CLEARLY STATED,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS, ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING? SEEING NONE, WE
STILL DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, BUT
WE'LL BE VOTING ON THIS, AND
WE'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
INVITATION. OKAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. NOTHING FURTHER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING ON. YOU WANT ME TO
READ THE NAMES? BUT I WOULD
LIKE, PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
MEMBERS THAT DO NOT HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
I WOULD SUGGEST YOU GET TO WORK
AND GET DOWN HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND, SO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT HERE, ARE
SENATOR ASHBY, SENATOR BRADFORD,
SENATOR GLASER, SENATOR JONES,
SENATOR NGUYEN, SENATOR PADILLA,
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND SENATOR
SEYARTO. AND I CALLED YOU OUT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
NGUYEN, FOR BEING HERE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. WE NEED ONE MORE
MEMBER. WELL, NOT NOW TWO. WE
LOST ONE. WE NEED TWO MORE
MEMBERS TO COME DOWN SO WE CAN
DO THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS. ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER 14. NO, WE DID
THAT. IT'S GOT TO COME DOWN TO
MY LEVEL HERE. COME ON. SO WE'LL
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
11. THAT'S AB 2589, SENATOR
PATTERSON, GOOD MORNING. GIVE
HIM YOU GIVE HIM A PROMOTION.
OH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
IT'S ONLY, IT'S NOT EVEN 10:00
YET. AND I'VE BEEN CALLED
SENATOR TWICE TODAY, SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE THAT UP.
DANILO, THIS IS YOUR DAY. YEAH.
YOU NEED SOME SOJU? OKAY. A
LITTLE TOO EARLY FOR THAT. ALL
RIGHT, SO WE'LL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY, FIRST, I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GREAT WORK BY
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF ON
HELPING TO NARROW THIS BILL A
LITTLE BIT AND MAKE SURE IT WAS
CLEAR ON WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WAS REALLY GREAT
WORK, AND, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE FIGURED OUT IN
MY, 18 MONTHS HERE AND BY THE
WAY, WHEN I STARTED, 18 MONTHS
AGO, I HAD A FULL HEAD OF HAIR.
AND, SINCE THEN, I'VE LOST IT.
BUT, IS TYPE 47 LICENSES ARE A
LOT LIKE EDUCATION FUNDING, I
DON'T THINK. I THINK VERY FEW
PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING
UNDERSTAND AND HOW IT WORKS. AND
AS YOU KNOW, PLACER COUNTY IS
ONE OF THE IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
AND FOR SOME VERY STRANGE
REASON, UNABLE TO GET ADDITIONAL
TYPE 47 LICENSES, WHICH IS
REALLY IMPACTED, NOT ONLY THE
TAHOE REGION, WHICH I DON'T
REPRESENT, BUT ALSO THE VERY BIG
SHOPPING CENTERS THAT ARE
COMPETING WITH, SMALL, SMALL
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE TRYING TO
STAY ALIVE. AND, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY PARTICIPATE. THEY'RE
COMPETING AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR
THESE TYPE 47 LICENSES. SO WE
DID HERE WITH THIS MEASURE IS WE
REALLY DID A FOR REALLY LARGE
SHOPPING CENTERS, LIKE A
SHOPPING MALL. WE HAVE A
WESTFIELD GALLERIA IN ROSEVILLE.
AND THAT WESTFIELD GALLERIA IS
ONE OF THE ONE OF THEIR HIGHEST
PERFORMING ASSETS. AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DOING A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS WITH IT TO MAKE IT MORE
OF AN ENTERTAINMENT HUB FOR, FOR
PLACER COUNTY, FOR SOUTH PLACER
COUNTY. BUT THEY'VE BEEN UNABLE
TO ATTRACT RESTAURANTS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT AND GET A
BROKER AND GET A LICENSE FOR A
RETAILER OR FOR A, FOR A
RESTAURANT. AND, YOU KNOW, THOSE
COSTS SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND SO WHAT THIS
MEASURE DOES IS IT ESSENTIALLY
ALLOWS LARGE RETAIL CENTERS IN
COUNTIES WHERE THEY ARE UNABLE
TO GET A LICENSE THROUGH THE
NORMAL PROCESS, BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALL USED UP ALREADY, IS TO GET A
LICENSE. AND ALSO THAT LICENSE
HAS TO STAY ON PREMISES. SO YOU
CAN'T THEREFORE TAKE THE LICENSE
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND USE IT THERE.
SO IT'S A VERY LIMITED TO HELP
THOSE LARGE RETAIL CENTERS IN
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS. HONESTLY,
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW, SOCIETY AND
THESE SHOPPING MALLS ARE MOVING
FROM JUST PLACES WHERE YOU GO
SHOPPING TO MORE OF AN
ENTERTAINMENT CENTER AND MORE
WHERE YOU'RE BRINGING YOUR
FAMILY, YOU'RE GOING TO THE
MOVIES, YOU'RE GOING BOWLING AT
SOME OF THESE LOCATIONS. AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO JUST CREATE SOME
ECONOMIC DRIVERS FOR NOT ONLY MY
DISTRICT, BUT ALL OF YOURS TOO.
AND SO WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. WE DO HAVE,
AUDREY, WRITE A CHECK FROM SHE
REPRESENTS WESTFIELD GALLERIA,
AND SHE'S HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AUDREY RITECHECK AND I
REPRESENT WESTFIELD. WE'RE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2589,
WHICH IS A CRITICAL MEASURE IN
HELPING MOVING FORWARD ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORTING
RETAIL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE,
INCLUDING IMPROVEMENT IN GROWTH
OPPORTUNITIES PLANNED BY
WESTFIELD. THIS BILL WOULD HELP
SUPPORT BUSINESSES AND ENSURE
RESTAURANTS AND RETAIL CENTERS
THRIVE BY ALLOWING ABC TO ISSUE
ADDITIONAL NEW ON SALE GENERAL
LICENSES FOR PUBLIC EATING
PLACES LOCATED IN A RETAIL
CENTER. MANY NEW AND GROWING
BUSINESSES THAT APPLY FOR A
LICENSE OFTEN MUST WAIT FOR
MONTHS OR EVEN LONGER, BEFORE
HAVING THE POSSIBILITY OF
SECURING A LICENSE, AND IF NO
LICENSE IS AVAILABLE FROM THE
STATE DUE TO POPULATION
RESTRICTIONS, BUSINESSES
INTERESTED IN OBTAINING AN ABC
LICENSE MAY PURCHASE ONE FROM AN
EXISTING LICENSEE FOR WHATEVER
THE PRICE THE MARKET WILL BEAR.
THIS IS A MAJOR IMPEDIMENT FOR
RESTAURANTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
EITHER NO AVAILABLE LICENSES TO
PURCHASE, OR THE MARKET HAS
DRIVEN UP THE PRICES FOR THE
SECONDARY LICENSE TO OVER
$250,000 OR MORE. AND THIS IS
THE EXACT CHALLENGE WE'RE
CURRENTLY FACING AS WE UNDERGO
CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
WESTFIELD GALLERIA IN ROSEVILLE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH EXPANSIONS AND CONTINUE TO
BRING NEW ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR MALL TO
HELP SUPPORT THE REGION. BUT THE
LACK OF AVAILABLE LIQUOR
LICENSES HAS MADE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO CONTRACT WITH NEW
RESTAURANTS WHO HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE LICENSE IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO WANT TO MOVE FORWARD. SO
FOR THESE REASONS, WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2589. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? MORNING. MORNING,
MISTER. CHAIR, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MIKE SKIP, ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE, WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL
KIND OF BLOW OPEN THE CAP,
STATEWIDE. AND THERE IS ALREADY
A LEGAL MECHANISM IN PLACE. IT'S
CALLED PROVING PUBLIC
CONVENIENCE AND NECESSITY. AND
I'M WONDERING IF THE DEVELOPERS
HAVE EVEN TRIED TO GO DOWN THAT
ROUTE, WHEN THE ABC SAYS THERE'S
A DENSITY ISSUE, THEY CAN APPLY
FOR A PUBLIC CONVENIENCE AND
NECESSITY WAIVER AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND VERY OFTEN, VERY
FREQUENTLY, THESE ARE GIVEN. SO
WE DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR THE
BILL TO BEGIN WITH. AND WE THINK
IT WILL OPEN THE DOOR TO, TO A
PROLIFERATION OF LICENSES LIKE
THIS IN AREAS THAT ARE ALREADY
OVER CONCENTRATED. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
BACK TO COMMITTEE. SENATOR WILK.
SORRY, BOB. ANYWAY. YEAH HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. AND I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT. IT'S REALLY
AN IMPORTANT ECONOMIC STEP, YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS, HER COMPANY
WALKED AWAY FROM FROM MY MALL IN
MY HOMETOWN, BECAUSE. THANK YOU.
THE CONCEPT OF MALLS IS DYING,
RIGHT. SO WE HAVE AN OUT. WE
HAVE AN OUTDOOR, LIKE AN OUTDOOR
PATIO MALL, WHICH I ACTUALLY
HELPED GET ENTITLED WAY BACK IN
2008. THAT'S PROSPERING. BUT THE
REST OF IT'S DYING AND THE NEW
OWNERS GOING IN THERE AND MAKING
THE TRANSFORMATIONS THAT THAT
YOU'RE ADVOCATING AND YEAH, AND
THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT, BUT
YOU DON'T WANT TO SQUEEZE OUT
THE LITTLE GUY EITHER, THE
LITTLE ENTREPRENEUR. SO THIS
MAKES TOTAL ECONOMIC SENSE TO
ME. AND IT'S GOING TO SAVE JOBS,
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S QUALITY OF
LIFE. GREAT BILL. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT. AND I WILL BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. PERFECT. ANYBODY
ELSE? SENATOR ARCHULETA, DO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING THAT WE WANTED TO
SAY? NO. I'M GOOD. IT'S A GREAT
BILL, SENATOR RUBIO. WELL, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS, YOU KNOW, I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS OF
THE GENTLEMAN THAT CAME UP. YOU
KNOW, SOMEONE THAT HARDLY EVER
SUPPORTS, YOU KNOW, EXPANSION OF
ALCOHOL OR DRUGS AND THE OTHER
THINGS. IT DOES GIVE ME PAUSE,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OUR KIDS GO,
YOU KNOW, TO THE MALL AND THAT'S
WHERE THEY GO GATHER IN. BUT I
KNOW THAT THEIR SAFEGUARDS, I
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT JUST
SERVING EVERY CHILD ALCOHOL.
RIGHT. BUT I DO KNOW THAT MALLS
AND BUSINESSES ARE UP AGAINST
THE CURRENT. AND IN TERMS OF
MANY GOING, YOU KNOW, SOME
ONLINE SALES. SO IT'S PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM, YOU KNOW, COMING TO
THE MALLS THESE DAYS. AND, AND
THERE'S A LOT OF BLIGHTED AREAS
THAT ARE STARTING TO, TO CREEP
UP AND SO I COULD SEE HOW MALLS
WANT TO REINVENT THEMSELVES AND
BE A SORT OF A HUB TO DRAW
PEOPLE IN. SO THAT IS WHY I WILL
GIVE THAT COURTESY VOTE. BUT
IT'S NECESSARY. I COULD SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S A TRICKLE
DOWN EFFECT. YOU KNOW, THE MALL
GOES AND THEN EVERYTHING AROUND
IT GOES. AND SO WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
ECONOMIC DRIVER. SO I WILL ALSO
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? WELL THANKS AGAIN. I
REALLY LIKE THE POINT ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE SMALL BUSINESSES
BECAUSE AGAIN, THEY'RE TRYING TO
HAVE TO COMPETE WITH THESE
LICENSES AND VICE VERSA. AND
THAT JUST DOESN'T DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT. BUT, YOU KNOW, WE TRY TO
TAKE A LIMITED, VERY LIMITED
APPROACH HERE. AND OBVIOUSLY, I
RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS FROM THE
OPPOSITION. I TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND YOU KNOW,
HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY I MEAN, WE CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE THERE ARE RISKS WITH
ALCOHOL. WE'VE ALL BEEN IMPACTED
BY IT SOMEHOW. AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. SO I DON'T WANT TO
DISMISS THAT. BUT ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME, I THINK MOST PEOPLE
DO DRINK RESPONSIBLY AND, THIS
IS REALLY TO HELP OUR
RESTAURANTS IN THOSE MALLS, SO
THE MALLS CAN STAY VIABLE. AND
THE LARGE SHOPPING CENTERS I
WANT TO SAY ONE MORE POINT.
ALSO, THIS ISN'T, THESE LICENSES
LIKELY WON'T GO TO THOSE, YOU
KNOW, SMALLER STRIP MALLS. YOU
KNOW, THAT WE SEE, YOU KNOW, IN
COMMUNITIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
, BECAUSE WE REALLY WANTED IT
FOR THE LARGE RETAIL CENTERS TO,
TO STAY AFLOAT. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES. GOOD LUCK
WITH THAT. THANK YOU. THAT'S IT.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE, YOU
CONGRATULATED AND THANKED STAFF,
BUT YOU DIDN'T I? YEAH, I ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS. I THANKED THEM,
BUT I'LL DENY IT. MY. JUST
KIDDING. NO. YES, I ACCEPT THEM.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE'LL VOTE ON THIS WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM. YEAH. GOOD CATCH. IT'S
MY PROFESSIONAL STAFF HERE.
AMAZING YOU NEED ME TO READ OUT
THE NAMES? WE NEED AUTHORS. OH,
WE NEED SO WE NEED NOW. NOW WE
NEED AUTHORS. AND I'M TELLING
YOU, MR. JARREAU IS GETTING VERY
ANNOYED BY THESE AUTHORS AND,
MEMBERS THAT AREN'T IN THE
COMMITTEE. HE'S BEEN HERE SINCE,
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA, PLEASE COME AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL. AND WE HAVE
IMMEDIATELY SOMEBODY MEMBER
MAINE SHINE. I'M GOING TO ADD
AGAIN, SENATOR ASHBY, SENATOR
GLAZER, SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, PLEASE COME TO THE
MEETING AND CAUSE US TO HAVE A
QUORUM. PLEASE RIGHT HERE. COME
ON UP. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MAINE
SHINE. WELCOME. WE'VE GOT FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 2435. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS SINCE 2012 COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS ENGAGED IN A
PUBLIC PROCESS WITH ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WHEN
PROPOSING AND ADOPTING
REGULATORY CHANGES. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED COVERED
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY RULEMAKING
AUTHORITY BECAUSE THEY MUST ACT
FASTER THAN THE TRADITIONAL
RULEMAKING PROCESS ALLOWS TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES IN LAWS THAT
AFFECT HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS. THE EMERGENCY
AUTHORITY EXPIRES ON JANUARY
ONE, 2025. CONSUMERS WILL BE AT
RISK OF SIGNIFICANT DELAY OF NEW
BENEFITS OR PROTECTIONS IF
COVERED CALIFORNIA IS NOT ABLE
TO QUICKLY CONFORM TO NEW STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICY COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS RECENTLY NEEDED,
OR WILL SOON NEED TO IMPLEMENT
NEW SUBSIDIES TO HELP MORE
PEOPLE AFFORD HEALTH CARE COSTS
TO CREATE A PROGRAM TO HELP
WORKERS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND REVISE
REGULATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
FEDERAL CHANGES, AB 2435 WOULD
EXTEND COVERED CALIFORNIA'S
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING PACKAGES UNTIL
JANUARY 1ST, 2030, IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY AND PROMPTLY REACT TO
BOTH ANNUAL AND ONGOING CHANGES
IN FEDERAL AND STATE RULES. ONCE
THE EMERGENCY RULEMAKING PROCESS
HAS BEEN COMPLETED. COVERED
CALIFORNIA MUST THEN COMPLETE
THE PERMANENT RULEMAKING PROCESS
WITHIN FIVE YEARS. THIS ALLOWS
FOR ANOTHER ROUND OF PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH COMMENTS AT
BOARD MEETINGS AND THROUGH THE
REGULAR RULEMAKING PROCESS. BY
PASSING AB 2435. THIS ENSURES
COVERED CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO
SERVE CONSUMERS WHILE ALSO
CONFORMING TO NEW STATE AND
FEDERAL POLICIES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS CHRISTINE
SMITH FROM HEALTH ACCESS AND
THEN KELLY GREEN AND ALISON
PEACE WITH COVERED CALIFORNIA
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, CHRISTINE
SMITH, HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2435 HEALTH ACCESS
HAS TESTIFIED AT EVERY SINGLE
MEETING OF THE COVERED
CALIFORNIA BOARD SINCE IT BEGAN
MEETING IN 2011. EVERY MEETING
FROM THE BEGINNING COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A CUSTOM THAT
A TOPIC IS DISCUSSED AT ONE
PUBLIC MEETING AND THEN VOTED ON
A MONTH LATER. AT A SUBSEQUENT
PUBLIC MEETING. THIS PRACTICE
MEANS THAT IF ANY INTERESTED
PARTY HAS CONCERNS ABOUT A
PROPOSED EMERGENCY REGULATION,
THEN THE BOARD HEARS THOSE
CONCERNS AND IN THE INTERVENING
MONTH THIS STAFF OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA CAN ATTEMPT TO
RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS BEFORE
THE MATTER RETURNS TO THE BOARD.
IN ADDITION, COVERED CALIFORNIA
STAFF ROUTINELY MEETS WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES, INCLUDING
CONSUMER ADVOCATES WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC MEETINGS.
AB 2435 CONTINUES EXISTING LAW
REQUIRING THIS PUBLIC PROCESS
AND FACILITATING THE INFORMAL
PROCESS OF CONSULTATION. WHILE
WE ARE NOT OVERALL FANS OF
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS, THIS
PUBLIC PROCESS AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
GIVES ANY INTERESTED PARTY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
SPEAKER, GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, FAITH BURGESS. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA AGENTS AND
HEALTH INSURANCE PROFESSIONALS,
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND THE CONSTANT COMMUNICATION
WE GET WITH COVERED CALIFORNIA
AND OUR ABILITY TO WEIGH IN AS
STAKEHOLDERS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ADJOURNING AND LAWS
BEING PASSED IN THE FALL AND
OPEN ENROLLMENT HAPPENING AS
SOON AS OCTOBER OR NOVEMBER, IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE
CONSISTENT GUIDELINES, CLEAR
DIRECTION FOR CONSUMERS, MAKING
SURE THAT AGENTS ARE ABLE TO
ARTICULATE AND MAKE FOLKS AWARE
OF THE NEW BENEFITS THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM, BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. SO WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THESE EFFORTS AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT MOVE
FORWARD. REMINDER TO STATE YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY AT THIS POINT. OR CHRIS
MARA, FOUNDER OF ELDERLY CARE
EVERYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE, WE'LL
TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE? I DON'T WANT TO
DISAPPOINT THEM. SO ARE WE GOING
TO BOYCOTT SENATOR ARCHULETA
TODAY? DID YOU, SENATOR WILK,
DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING YOU
WANTED TO SAY? YEAH, THIS THIS
IS A GREAT BILL, REALLY, WHAT I
WANT TO SAY, BECAUSE I MAY NOT
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY. WE
BOTH CAME IN AT THE SAME TIME.
CLASS OF 2012. IT WAS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT THE
ACA. ACA HAS WORKED WAY, WAY
BETTER THAN I EVER THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO WORK. YOU'VE STAYED
ENGAGED IN THIS HEALTH, HEALTH
AND INSURANCE SPACE YOUR ENTIRE
CAREER. SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE. HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
WELCOME GREAT. ANYBODY ELSE,
SENATOR ARCHULETA? YES THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU KNOW,
INSURANCE IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
THING IN OUR LIVES RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALL WE'RE HEARING FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS. BUT TO HAVE THE
INSURANCE, THE AFFORDABLE, TYPE
OF INSURANCE THAT WE NEED FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS, ALL OF US, WE
HEAR IT ALL THE TIME. AND I
THINK THE EXTENSION IS SO VITAL.
SO, AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
I'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE THE BILL.
DO WE HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT NOW?
NO. UNIMAS. YES OKAY. ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS THIS
BILL? WE DO HAVE A MOTION. BUT
IT'S WHEN THE TIME COMES BY,
SENATOR ARCHULETA, FIRST ONE
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR THAT,
SENATOR. AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN I VOTE WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL BE VOTING ON YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU. WHICH LEADS ME.
WHICH LEADS ME TO BRING UP ONCE
AGAIN THAT SENATOR ASHBY,
SENATOR GLASER, SENATOR JONES,
SEN PADILLA, SENATOR PORTANTINO.
I KNOW I WENT TO GRAB PEOPLE.
PLEASE COME IN. WE WERE JUST
GOOFING AROUND, GET TO WORK.
ALCOHOL MAKE A MOTION FOR WALKIE
TALKIES FOR A CHAIR. YEAH, WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. AB 2094 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA. GOOD MORNING. DO
YOU THINK I'M BEING HEAVY
HANDED? GOOD MORNING, SENATORS,
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2094.
WE'RE GOING TO INTERRUPT THIS
NORMAL PROGRAMING AND GO TO,
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL DODD HERE. DODD HERE.
WILK PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT.
ALVARADO. GILL. PRESENT.
ALVARADO PRESENT. ARCHULETA.
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. ASHBY.
BRADFORD GLASER. JONES. I'M
HERE. JONES HERE. NGUYEN. HERE.
NGUYEN. HERE. OKUBO. HERE TROBO.
HERE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO. ROTH.
HERE. ROTH HERE. RUBIO. PRESENT.
RUBIO. PRESENT. SATO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WE HAVE A QUORUM. MR.
JARREAU IS HAPPY AT THIS POINT
IN TIME. I APPRECIATE THAT. DO
WE HAVE A RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME?
WE'LL MOVE. TO THE CONSENT
ITEMS. THE CALENDAR INCLUDES
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 1935.
RUBIO ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 3285.
THE COMMITTEE BILL, ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN, AB 2469. ITEM EIGHT, AB
2776. RODRIGUEZ ITEM 12 2886 ADR
CURRY AND NUMBER 1632 61 BY
FONG. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ARCHULETA AND SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL DODD. YES, I DODD
I WILK I WILK I ALVARADO GIL I
ALVARADO I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ASHBY I BRADFORD
GLASER JONES I JONES I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I OKUBO I OKUBO I
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH. ROTH I
RUBIO I RUBIO I SATO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS TEN BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. OKAY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA, THANKS
FOR BEING SO PATIENT WITH US AS
WE CONDUCTED A LITTLE BIT OF
BUSINESS HERE. SO PLEASE
PROCEED. NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
SENATOR NÓ, PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2094, COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE THE BEDROCK OF
LOCAL HIGHER EDUCATION. AND THEY
OPEN COUNTLESS DOORS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PURSUING DEGREES
AND CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS. SENATE
BILL 2094 BRINGS PARITY TO
BAKERSFIELD COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND EXPAND BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FOR BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE TO DRIVE FUNDING FOR
STUDENT SERVICES AND ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MARK MCDONALD. ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT,
AB 2094 WOULD PROVIDE A NARROW
EXCEPTION TO STATE LAW THAT
PROHIBITS ALCOHOL SALES AND
CONSUMPTION ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROPERTY AND FACILITIES.
MEMORIAL STADIUM IS AN IMPORTANT
GATHERING PLACE THAT SHAPES THE
IDENTITY OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT THE DISTRICT SERVES. THE
STADIUM IS A HISTORIC VENUE THAT
HAS HOSTED SPORTING EVENTS AS
WELL AS GRADUATION CEREMONIES
AND STATEWIDE PERFORMING ARTS
EVENTS. IT HOLDS NEARLY 200,000
PEOPLE, AND IT WOULD BE A GREAT
GATHERING PLACE FOR EVENTS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE OTHERWISE
SURPASS THE CENTRAL VALLEY. SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION? ANY IN OPPOSITION?
SOMEBODY NEW? GOOD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR AND
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS RAUL VERDUGO, SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOL POLICY ALLIANCE OR
STATEWIDE ALLIANCE, REPRESENTING
OVER 50 ORGANIZATIONS, WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL BECAUSE,
LIKE MANY OTHER INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING, IT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL CONTINUES THE
CONCERNING PATTERN OF OFFSETTING
COSTS TO HIGHER EDUCATION BY
SELLING ALCOHOL ADS THAT WILL BE
AIMED AT STUDENTS, ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH, EACH YEAR, OVER 1500
COLLEGE STUDENTS BETWEEN 18 AND
24 DIE FROM ALCOHOL RELATED
INJURIES, INCLUDING MOTOR
VEHICLE CRASHES. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
ASK THE COMMITTEE, THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, TO OPPOSE THE BILL AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MIKE
SKIP, ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL
JUSTICE, IN ADDITION TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE HAS JUST, TESTIFIED
TO, THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ON
THIS CAMPUS ARE ACTUALLY 19
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER. AND WE
KNOW THAT EXPOSURE TO
ADVERTISING MAKES A TEENAGER
MORE LIKELY TO START DRINKING
AND INCREASES THE AMOUNT THEY
CONSUME. WHEN THEY DO DRINK.
IT'S WELL ESTABLISHED, AND THE
RESEARCH SHOWS IT ALSO INCREASES
BINGE DRINKING. WHATEVER THE
COLLEGE HOPES TO GAIN
FINANCIALLY, THE STUDENTS WILL
LOSE IN TERMS OF ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE, QUALITY OF LIFE AND
IN THE WORST CASE, DURATION OF
LIFE. FOR THIS REASON, WE ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS
COME TO THE MIC, I'M GOING TO
TURN BACK TO OUR MEMBERS HERE.
SENATORS WILK GO AHEAD. SO I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND YOU. GREAT.
BILL, FORMER RESIDENT LONG TIME
AGO IN ANOTHER LIFE IN
BAKERSFIELD MEMORIAL STADIUM IS
A CULTURAL HUB THERE. AND WITH
THAT, I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR
YOU, THOUGH. YOU DON'T HAVE KERN
COUNTY, CORRECT? THAT IS CORRECT
. OUR DEAR COLLEAGUE AND NOW A
CONGRESSMAN, MR. VINCE FALCO.
OKAY, THAT MAKES SENSE TO
PRESENT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
HIM. I SHOULD HAVE PUT THAT
TOGETHER MYSELF. YOU KNOW, I
DIDN'T. IT'S EARLY. SO ANYWAY,
WITH THAT. I, SUPPORT THE BILL,
AND I WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SIR. ANYBODY ELSE
? SENATOR CHOBO. SO THIS IS A
COLLEGE CAMPUS, A JUNIOR COLLEGE
CAMPUS IN COLLEGE CAMPUS,
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUS. SO ANY THOUGHTS ON THE
ON THE CONCERNS I BELIEVE I
YEAH, I, I CAN MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ON THE, COMMENT THAT
THE AVERAGE AGE IS 19. THAT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT STUDENTS THAT ARE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND NOT
ACTUALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE ACTUAL AGE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IS
ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN THOSE AT
CSU AND UC. AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS AS A VENUE THAT COULD BRING
IN, CONCESSIONS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE PASS BY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
OTHER VENUES IN THE AREA THAT
MAKE SENSE. SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE ADVERTISING HAPPENING?
HAPPENING DURING, FOR EXAMPLE,
CONCERTS OR, OTHER SPORTING
EVENTS, THINGS LIKE THAT. SINCE
YOU, YOU'RE DID YOU THINK I'M
GOOD? THANK YOU. SINCE YOU, WERE
TALKING ABOUT VENUE, I HEARD YOU
SAY THAT THIS WOULD HOLD 200,
200,000. YEAH. WITHSTANDING BIG
HOUSE IN MICHIGAN HOLDS ABOUT
105. HOW DOES THIS HOW DO YOU.
IT'S BIG. THAT INCLUDES STANDING
ROOM ONLY. WE'RE GOING TO NEED A
FIELD TRIP DOWN THERE TO. I GOT
TO SEE TWO. WE CAN WE CAN BRING
THE CHANCELLOR UP HERE AND HAVE
YOU GUYS COME DOWN FOR SURE.
OKAY. NO, WE NEED TO INVITE
EVERYBODY TO. WHEN MY SANTA
CLARITA COUGARS COME UP TO PLAY
THE DRILLING. OKAY, I'LL GO
THEN. YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND, AND I DO BECAUSE I'M
A FORMER, BOARD OF TRUSTEE
MEMBER, IS A LOT OF TIMES THESE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE REALLY A
CULTURAL, CULTURAL HUB. SO,
LIKE, I USED TO BE ON COLLEGE OF
THE CANYONS BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
IF YOU DRIVE UP THE I-5, YOU SEE
THAT, WE HAVE A PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER WHERE WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF ARTISTS COME IN, THE FOOTBALL
STADIUM IS USED FOR, EASTER,
EASTER SERVICE, CONCERTS,
FOOTBALL GAMES, MARCHING BAND
COMPETITIONS. AND HE'S RIGHT.
THE AVERAGE AGE OF A COLLEGE,
THAT'S KIND OF A SPURIOUS
ARGUMENT. THE AVERAGE AGE IS
ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN THE UC
SYSTEM. IT'S ABOUT 30 YEARS OLD
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
COMING BACK FOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING IN THOSE THINGS. AND SO
I THINK THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC MEASURE, AND I HOPE
EVERYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS IT. SENATOR DODD, MY
NAME IS BOB GEROW, AND I'M I WAS
HERE ON ANOTHER BILL, BUT, IN MY
PAST LIFE, I WAS THE STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT AT BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE. ALL RIGHT. AND I'D LIKE
TO SAY THAT MEMORIAL COLISEUM IS
HUGE. THE BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE
RENEGADES WERE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME, THE JUNIOR COLLEGE
FOOTBALL CHAMPIONS IN THE
COUNTRY. THERE'S A BIG MOVIE
THAT YOU ALL MIGHT WANT TO LOOK
AT. IT WAS ROBIN WILLIAMS
STARRED IN IT CALLED THE BEST OF
TIMES, BUT THE BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE MEMORIAL COLISEUM HAS
HELD, SEVERAL EVENTS. IT IS, AS
MR. FLORES SAID, IT'S A CENTRAL
HUB LOCATION FOR PEOPLE THAT
COME FROM ALL OVER, FROM
TEHACHAPI, FROM UP NEAR FRESNO.
IT'S A FEEDER COLLEGE TO THE
FRESNO COLLEGE BULLDOGS TEAM,
AND IT IS A BIG, BIG COMMUNITY
VENUE IN KERN COUNTY THAT, I
THINK THE BILL WOULD SERVE A
GREAT PURPOSE FOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. DROUGHT. SINCE,
I'VE USED YOU IN SUPPORT OF MY
EFFORT TO GET A QUORUM HERE
TODAY. I'M GLAD YOU, GRACED US
WITH THAT, AMAZING BACKGROUND
INFORMATION. I'M ENLIGHTENED.
LET'S VOTE ON THIS THING. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DISRESPECTFUL.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WILK. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL DODD. AYE. DODD
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD. GLASER GLASER. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. NGUYEN NGUYEN
AYE. OKOBO AYE. OKOBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO.
ROTH AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
CITRO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
SATO. SATO. AYE. HOW MANY? THANK
YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. SIR 11.
THAT HAS 11 VOTES. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. JUST DON'T TAKE.
SO WE'RE WAITING ON, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA. BUT I THINK WHAT
WE'LL DO RIGHT NOW, FOR THE SAKE
OF THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE AND
LIFT THE CALLS. YES, WE HAVE ON
SOME OF THEM. SOME OF THEM. SO
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL, ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. OR DO YOU
WANT TO START WITH THE CONSENT?
CONSENT WE'LL START OUT WITH THE
CONSENT ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE.
SATO HIGH. SIERRA. DOE. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS CONSENT 13.
THAT HAS 13 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. WE NEED A MOTION
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
THAT'S AB 2068. ORTEGA. NO, NOT
CORRECT. ACCORDING TO MY NOTES,
SENATOR ARCHULETA MADE THE
MOTION. WELL, WOW. THANK YOU.
YOU WEREN'T HERE YET BECAUSE YOU
WERE IN THE CAR ACCIDENT.
BECAUSE WE'RE HERE. WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE. YEAH, WELL, THERE WE
GO. OKAY, WELL, HE. SO THE
MOTION IS BY ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS TO LABOR
COMMITTEE. DODD AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. JONES. NO. JONES.
NO NGUYEN. OKUBO. AYE OKUBO.
AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO CITRO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. 12 901 9 TO 1 9 TO 1.
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL. I
BELIEVE I COULD BE WRONG BECAUSE
I HAD JUST GOTTEN HERE. BUT TO
SENATOR WILK MADE THE MOTION
HERE. DON'T WANT TO MAKE THAT
MISTAKE TWICE. WE'LL NOW OPEN
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR,
AB 2069. GALLAGHER, SECRETARY,
OPENED THE ROLL, PLEASE. MOTION
IS DUE. PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DODD I DODD I WILK I
WILK I ALVARADO GILL I ALVARADO.
GILL I ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY. ASHBY I BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER. I JONES. I JONES. I.
NGUYEN. NGUYEN I OKUBO I. OKUBO
I. PADILLA. PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO I. ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO
. SATO. SIERRA I. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS 12. 12 AS 12 VOTES. WE'LL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL. WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 2094, BY FLORA
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD PADILLA,
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE.
RUBIO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THAT'S
1212 HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL, FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX, AB 2435 MAIENSCHEIN. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON SENATOR WILK
MADE THE CALL. I MADE THE
MOTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. A MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DODD. I DODD I WILK I WILK I
ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I ASHBY
ASHBY I BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER. I JONES. NÓ. JONES. NÓ.
NGUYEN. NGUYEN NO. OKUBO. NO.
OKUBO. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I. ROTH ROTH I RUBIO.
SATO. CRLA ONO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. BILL. HAS EIGHT FOUR I'S
AND FOUR NO'S. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. WE'LL NOW OPEN THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE. AB 2983.
RODRIGUEZ MOTION BY RUBIO,
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE. DODD I DODD I WILK I
WILK I ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO
GIL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY ASHBY I BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER I JONES. HI JONES I
NGUYEN. NGUYEN I OKUBO I. OKUBO
I. PADILLA. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO
. SATO. SERRADO I. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS BILL HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. WILL NOW OPEN
THE ROLL ON ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
2543 ARAMBULA RUBIO. AND WE HAVE
A MOTION BY, SENATOR RUBIO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. DODD I DODD I WILK.
NO. WILK. NO. ALVARADO. GIL
ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. ASHBY I
BRADFORD. GLASER. I GLASER. I
JONES. I'M SORRY I MISSED THE
BILL. AB 2543 ARAMBULA MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. JONES NÓ NGUYEN.
OCHOA B¢O NØ. OCHOA B¢O NØ.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO. SATO. NO.
SATO. NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS NO.
OUR AUTHORS HERE. AWESOME. IT
HAS SEVEN NÓ NGUYEN. NO. NGUYEN
SCOTT. YOU MEAN RUBIO. ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD NGUYEN. NO.
NGUYEN. NO. PADILLA RUBIO.
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
858 EYES, FIVE NOSE. THAT BILL
WILL BE PUT ON CALL. WE'LL NOW
OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11 AB 2589. WE HAD A
MOTION ON THAT DON'T WE. I'M NO
LONGER CHAIR SO I DIDN'T WRITE
IT DOWN. YEAH. THE MOTION WE
HAVE A MOTION. I THOUGHT IT WAS
ME, BUT YEAH, IT WAS ME. WE'RE
GOING WITH WILK. NO, IT WAS ME.
NO, I'M THINKING ABOUT IT. OPEN
THE ROLL, PLEASE. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
I DODD I WILK I WILK I ALVARADO
GIL ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY 2589 2589.
ASHBY I BRADFORD. GLASER. GLASER
I, JONES I JONES I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN, I OCHOA. BOW I OCHOA.
BOW I, PADILLA PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO.
RUBIO I SATO. SIERRA I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. 13. IT'S 13.
13 ZERO. THAT BILL IS ON CALL,
WE NOW OPEN THE ROLL AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER 13 AB 3203
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION BY WILK
MOTION IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD I
DODD I WILK I WILK I ALVARADO
GIL I ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY. ASHBY I
BRADFORD. GLASER GLASER I JONES
I. JONES I NGUYEN NGUYEN I OKUBO
32 003 32 030I OCHOA, VÚI,
PADILLA, PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
ROTH ROTH I RUBIO I RUBIO I
CIERTO CIERTO I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
. 1313 THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER 14. THAT'S AB
3069 DAVIES. MOTION BY
ARCHULETA. MOTION IS TO CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. DODD.
I DODD I WILK I WILK I ALVARADO
GIL I ALVARADO GIL I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I ASHBY.
ASHBY I BRADFORD. GLASER.
GLASER. I JONES I. JONES I.
NGUYEN I NGUYEN I. OKUBO.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO
I. ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO I RUBIO I
CIERTO. CIERTO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. 12. THERE'S 12. GIL HAS
12 VOTES. WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 15.
THAT'S AB 3206 70. MEMBER
MCKINNEY TO COME ON UP, WELCOME.
BACK. OKAY. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, OF
THE COMMITTEE, AB 3206 IS A BILL
THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
SPECIFIC ENTERTAINMENT VENUE IN
MY DISTRICT TO OFFER AFTER HOUR
ALCOHOL SALES UNDER LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES. MUCH LIKE CITIES
AROUND THE WORLD, MANY
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE SEEKING TO
NAVIGATE A GROWING DEMAND FOR.
AFTER 2 A.M. RETAIL ALCOHOL
SALES BALANCED WITH THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. AB 3206 TAKES A NEW
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
DEMAND FOR AFTER HOUR ALCOHOL
SALES BY AUTHORIZING A SPECIFIC
ENTERTAINMENT VENUE, NOT AN
ENTIRE CITY, TO OFFER AFTER HOUR
ALCOHOL SALES UNDER LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF SAFEGUARDS,
INCLUDING LIMITING THE SIZE OF
THE VENUE, LIMITING THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS ALLOWED IN THE
VENUE, LIMITING THE DAYS THAT
THE VENUE CAN OFFER AFTER HOUR
ALCOHOL SALES, AND REQUIRING
LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL APPROVAL IN
ORDER TO MITIGATE POTENTIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS. THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES
A 2030 SUNSET WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS BOB GIRAUD, REPRESENTING THE
INTUIT DOME AND THE LOS ANGELES
CLIPPERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MR. STEVE BALLMER
AND THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS,
ASKING YOU TO APPROVE A Ã, 2500
SQUARE FOOT VENUE INSIDE THE
INTUIT DOME, WHICH IS SCHEDULED
TO BE FINISHED ON JUNE 20TH. IN
FACT, THE STATE OF THE STATE THE
MAYOR'S STATE OF THE STATE OF
THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD WILL BE IN
THAT IN THAT VENUE, THE AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, MCHENRY SAID IT
WILL BE AT A LIMITED CAPACITY, A
LIMITED NUMBER OF NIGHTS PER
YEAR. AND, I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? COME FORWARD NOW.
MR. CHAIR, SENATORS FRED JONES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL PROBLEMS,
WHICH IS PRIMARILY A FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATION. WE'RE ALSO PART OF
THE STATEWIDE COALITION, KAPPA.
THE CONCERN ISN'T WITH THIS
SINGLE VENUE. THE CONCERN IS
WITH THE BROADER DEBATE ABOUT
LIFTING LAST CALL FROM 2 A.M. TO
4 A.M. WE'VE HAD THAT DEBATE NOW
FOR SIX YEARS ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS, AND EACH OF THOSE YEARS
THAT HAS STOPPED WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOW IS THE
APPROACH OF MAKING THIS A
DISTRICT BY DISTRICT, VENUE BY
VENUE, EROSION OF THAT STATEWIDE
LAST CALL, WHICH HAS BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR OVER A CENTURY. SO WE
ARE TAKING A PRINCIPLED STAND
AGAINST ANY OF THOSE EFFORTS,
EVEN A DISTRICT BILL APPROACH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RAUL
VERDUGO, SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE, EXTENDING LAST CALL
TIMES TO 4 A.M, FORCES
SURROUNDING CITIES TO ABSORB THE
HIGH COST AND NEEDLESSLY,
NEEDLESSLY CARRY THE BURDEN OF
ALCOHOL RELATED HARMS AND
FATALITIES AS INEBRIATED
TRAVELERS PASS THROUGH THE
ABUTTING TOWNS AND COMMUNITIES
AS COPPA, WE ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOT SUPPORT AB
306, THE DOCUMENTED RISKS OF
EXTENDED LAST CALL TIMES ARE NOT
JUST THEORETICAL, BUT REAL, BUT
A REAL THREAT TO THE RESIDENTS
OF INGLEWOOD AND ITS SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. THE POTENTIAL FOR
VIP TRAVELERS AND LOCAL
COMMUTERS TO CROSS PATHS IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOURS,
PARTICULARLY PARTICULARLY DURING
PEAK COMMUTING. COMMUTING TIMES,
IS A PRACTICAL CONCERN THAT THIS
COMMITTEE CANNOT IGNORE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR, COMMITTEE MEMBERS MIKE
SKIPP, ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL
JUSTICE, WE TOO ARE PROUD
SUPPORTERS AND MEMBERS OF CAPA
AND WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. THIS IS AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I'M GOING
TO BRING THIS BACK TO MEMBERS.
NOW. DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
CONCERNS? SENATOR SEYARTO
PROBABLY KNEW THIS WAS COMING.
WHAT ARE THESE OCCASIONAL EVENTS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT
THIS IS NARROWED DOWN TO, THAT
ARE GOING TO LAST UNTIL 4:00 IN
THE MORNING? THE I'M GOING TO
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESS, SIR. SENATOR SENATOR,
WE, WE HAVE, WE WILL HAVE, FROM
TIME TO TIME, WE WILL HAVE
CONCERTS. WE WILL HAVE SPECIAL
PARTIES, I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE GROWTH AND THE
RESURGENCE OF THE CITY OF
INGLEWOOD, BUT WE HAVE SOFI
STADIUM. WE HAVE, THE FORUM, WE
HAVE THE HOLLYWOOD PARK CASINO.
WITH ALL OF THAT, WE HAVE
1000FT² OF, OR EXCUSE ME,
1,000,000FT² OF OFFICE AND
RETAIL. WE'RE BUILDING A NEW A
NEW RITZ-CARLTON HOTEL SO THAT
THE PLAYERS WHO COME IN AND OUT
OF TOWN TO PLAY THEIR GAMES CAN,
CAN COME FROM LAX INTO
INGLEWOOD, WHICH IS ABOUT A FIVE
MINUTE DRIVE, AND LEAVE. SO
THOSE THOSE EVENTS ARE GOING TO
BE PARTIES HOSTED BY THE TEAM
AND SOME AFTER HOURS PARTIES
HOSTED AFTER CERTAIN
ENTERTAINMENT EVENTS, THEY WILL
BE ADVERTISED THERE IS A
SAFEGUARD IN THE BILL FOR THE
CITY COUNCIL OF INGLEWOOD TO
APPROVE, THE EVENTS WHERE THE,
WHERE, WHERE THESE EVENTS WILL
TAKE PLACE IN THIS FACILITY.
OKAY. WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I AM INTIMATELY, FAMILIAR
WITH THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD. I
WORKED THERE FOR 23 YEARS AND
SERVED THAT COMMUNITY FOR 23
YEARS. AND I WATCHED THE
DEVELOPMENT. ALL OF WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT, THIS
MOVEMENT, YOU KNOW, CONCERTS AND
ABOUT 11:00, 1130, GAMES END AT
TEN, EXTENDING DRINKING HOURS
FROM 4 HOURS TO 6 HOURS, IS NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE IN INGLEWOOD, THAT SOME
ARE GETTING UP AND STARTING
THEIR COMMUTES AT EARLY HOURS,
AND, AND I'M NOT QUITE SURE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED. IF PEOPLE
WANT TO HAVE A PARTY, THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR PARTY AT THE HOTEL,
WHERE THEY CAN STAY AND NOT GET
INTO THE CAR AND, AND GET ON TO
ONE OF THE 105, THE 405 OR THE
110 AND START DRIVING, AFTER
DRINKING AN EXTRA TWO HOURS, SO,
YOU KNOW, I AM THESE KINDS OF
BILLS HAVE COME TO US IN THE
PAST. NOT SPECIFICALLY FOR ONE
CITY IN INGLEWOOD. BUT INGLEWOOD
SHOULD NOT BE SINGLED OUT TO BE
TREATED ANY DIFFERENT THAN
ANAHEIM OR ANY OF THE OTHERS.
AND IF THEY'RE DOING THIS, I
DON'T THINK THERE THERE'S ANY
EXCLUSIONS FOR THESE OTHER
COMMUNITIES EITHER, THAT WE KNOW
OF. DO YOU KNOW OF ANY OF THE
EXCLUSIONS FOR OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE ARENAS? NO, I DO NOT.
BUT THIS WOULD BE FOR THE VENUE,
AND THIS WOULD NOT BE FOR THE
ENTIRE VENUE. THIS WOULD JUST BE
FOR A CERTAIN SECTION OF IT. SO
EVERYBODY Kò THIS WON'T BE FOR
LIKE THE ENTIRE, INTUIT DOME
WON'T BE ABLE TO. I UNDERSTAND
IT'S FOR THE IT'S JUST FOR THE
ONE VENUE. AND SO NO, I DO NOT
KNOW. THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS THAT THIS
HAPPENED. YES. BUT PEOPLE HAVE
TO LEAVE THAT VENUE TO GO
EITHER. I DON'T CARE. SOME OF
THEM MAY WALK ACROSS TO THE
HOTEL, BUT SOME ARE GOING TO GET
IN THEIR CAR AND THEY'RE GOING
TO DRIVE AWAY AND, AND, AND
GIVING THEM TWO HOURS OF EXTRA
FUEL AND MORE TRAFFIC ON THE
ROADS AT THAT TIME, IS A RECIPE
FOR DISASTER. SO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DOING, I MEAN, THAT WAS
WHEN I WAS WORKING. THAT WAS THE
BEWITCHING HOUR WE WERE OUT
PRETTY MUCH ALL NIGHT, BUT A LOT
OF TIMES, RIGHT IT WHEN THE BAR
IS CLOSED BETWEEN ONE AND ABOUT
THREE, WE WERE GETTING CALLS AND
THOSE CALLS THAT WE GOT WERE
HIDEOUS CALLS. AND BECAUSE THERE
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LACKING THE JUDGMENT, THEY NEED
TO DRIVE, DRIVE CAREFULLY AND
THEY'RE HITTING PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT BE OUT, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT STAY OUT IN
INGLEWOOD AT, AND I JUST DON'T
SEE HOW THIS, CONTRIBUTES TO ANY
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND I DON'T I
DON'T SEE HOW IT'S A BIG REVENUE
GENERATOR FOR THE COMMUNITY,
IT'S A, YOU KNOW, SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PARTY VENUE.
LIKE I SAID, THE PLAYERS STAY
OVER AT THE RITZ CARLTON. THEY
HAVE LOTS OF PARTY VENUES OVER
THERE, AND THEY CAN AFFORD IT.
AND THEY CAN STAY THERE AND NOT
HAVE TO IMPACT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OF ALL OF THE OTHER COMMUNITIES.
I'M TALKING HAWTHORNE, CULVER
CITY, LA CITY, ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT SURROUND
INGLEWOOD, THEY ALL GET IMPACTED
BY THIS. AND SO I AM NOT GOING
TO BE VOTING FOR THIS. AND I'VE
ALWAYS RESISTED THE EFFORTS TO
MOVE OUR DRINKING TIME EVEN
FARTHER INTO THE MORNING, AND SO
I JUST WON'T BE ON BOARD WITH
THIS ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND BECAUSE IT HAS TO BE
APPROVED BY OUR INGLEWOOD CITY
COUNCIL, OUR MAYOR, MAYOR BUTTS,
WAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR MANY,
MANY, MANY YEARS. SO IT HAS TO
GO THROUGH HIM BEFORE IT CAN
HAPPEN. ANYWAY, YOU CAN TELL
JAMES THAT KELLY SAYS, I DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN. I WORKED
ALONGSIDE MAYOR BUTTS WHILE HE
WAS IN THE PD AND I WAS IN THE
FIRE SERVICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. DID YOU WANT TO. I THINK
THAT THE AUTHOR ANSWERED MY
QUESTION THAT THE INGLEWOOD CITY
COUNCIL, THE ELECTED LEADERS
THERE, HAVE THE FINAL SAY ON
THIS MATTER, AND I'M SURE
THEY'LL BE SENSITIVE TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND SO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND MOVE IT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS, ARE THEY
GOING TO BE IDENTIFIED FROM, YOU
KNOW, BEING IN THE STADIUM AND
THEN MOVING INTO THE ROOM? HOW
DO YOU IDENTIFY WHO'S AUTHORIZED
TO GO IN AND ARE YOU GOING TO BE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL SECURITY
AT 233 AND FOUR IN THE MORNING?
SENATOR ARCHULETA, TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, THE ANSWER IS
YES. THIS WILL OPERATE MORE LIKE
A CLUB FUNCTION. LIKE, I'M SURE
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THE
FORUM CLUB FUNCTION, WHICH IS
ALSO OWNED BY MR. BALLMER. SO
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A MEMBER
AND YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE
INVITED. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE SEEING? NONE. MAY
HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR GLAZER
MADE THE MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? ASSEMBLY MEMBER? YES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THE MOTION HERE IS
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DODD. AYE. DODD
AYE. WILK ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD.
GLASER GLASER. AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. NGUYEN OKUBO. NO.
OKUBO. NO PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH I. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO SATO. NO. SATO. NO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SEVEN VOTES
FOR TWO AGAINST. NO NGUYEN.
NGUYEN. NO. SEVEN VOTES FOR
THREE AGAINST. THAT THAT WILL
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
. CHAIR IS MY VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER SIX. WHEN IT COMES UP
AGAIN PLEASE. OKAY. WE'LL DO
THAT. DO WE GO THROUGH THEM ONE
MORE TIME? OKAY. SO LET'S OPEN
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT, ITEMS,
PLEASE. BOY, IS THAT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING? THAT'S WHAT I
SAID. YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT. OPEN
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT ITEMS,
PLEASE. ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
PADILLA. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STILL
13 ZERO. OKAY, WE'LL OPEN UP ON
FILE. ITEM NUMBER THREE. ORTEGA.
MOTION BY ARCHULETA. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD NGUYEN PADILLA
. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. SATO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THAT'S TEN.
BILL HAS TEN VOTES. 10 TO 1, PUT
THAT ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 2069. GALLAGHER. THE
VOTES 12 ZERO ZERO. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. PADILLA. RUBIO RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. 13.
BILLS ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE 2094 FLORIDA VOTE IS 12
ZERO. SECRETARY OPENED THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD PADILLA
RUBIO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STILL
HAS 12. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX 2435 MAIN
HÌNH. IT HAS EIGHT VOTES FOR AND
FOUR AGAINST, OPEN THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ALVARADO, GILL. I TO NO.
ALL RIGHT. ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD AGUILAR. RUBIO I RUBIO
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. BILL HAS
845 AGAINST. IS THAT RIGHT. GOES
ON CALL FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
2983. RODRIGUEZ OPEN THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD
PADILLA HI. PADILLA I RUBIO
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. BILL
HAS 14 VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL. OPEN THE ROLL ON
FILE. ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2543.
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD PADILLA.
PADILLA I SMALL. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. THE BILL HAS NINE FOR
AND FIVE AGAINST BILLS ON CALL
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 2589.
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD PADILLA.
HI. PADILLA. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS 14. BILL HAS 14 VOTES.
BILLS ON CALL FILE NUMBER 13 AB
32 03A CURRY SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. MEMBERS BRADFORD.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS BILL HAS 14
VOTES. THAT'S ON CALL, NOW MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 3206
KEINER. DO I HAVE THAT RIGHT?
1430 69 ÁP NÓ. EXCUSE ME, I'M ON
THE WRONG SHEET. AB 14, FILE
ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 3069. DAVIES,
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MEMBERS. BRADFORD OCHOA. B¢O.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. BILL HAS 14 VOTES. 13.
WHICH ONE IS THAT? AB 3069, FILE
ITEM NUMBER 14. YES. NO LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL. YEAH, I MISS
THAT. I DON'T KNOW HOW. AB 3069
DAVIES. ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD
OCHOA B¢O Ã OCHOA. VÚI. THAT'S
14 I APOLOGIZE, NO WORRIES. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. WE'LL NOW OPEN
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 15,
AB 3206. MCKINNEY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS. WILK
ALVARADO. GIL NÓ. ALVARADO. GIL.
NO. BRADFORD PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO. I'M SORRY.
CARDOZA NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
84844. AGAINST. THAT BILL IS ON
CALL. WHERE IS. WHO ELSE ARE?
YES PADILLA. OKAY, WE'LL START
AT THE TOP. WHERE, SENATOR
PADILLA HAS NOT GONE ON RECORD
YET, SO WE'LL OPEN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, PLEASE. ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
1414. THE BILL IS ON CALL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 2068. OPEN
THE ROLL, PLEASE. BRADFORD
NGUYEN. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
SATO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. BILL HAS
11 VOTES, ONE AGAINST. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB 2069. GALLAGHER, OPEN
THE ROLL, PLEASE. BRADFORD
PADILLA. HI. PADILLA, AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS BILL HAS 14
VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 2094.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. BRADFORD.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. RUBIO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. 1313 BOYLE
HAS 13 VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. ITEM SIX. ITEM NUMBER SIX
2435 MAIN HÌNH. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. BRADFORD PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS NINE
FOUR. THE BILL HAS NINE FIVE, 9
TO 5. THAT BILL IS ON CALL. FILE
ITEM NINE. YOU GOT THAT? OKAY.
SO NOW WE'RE JUST OPEN FOR
BRADFORD. IS THAT COMMITTEE
STILL GOING. IS HE CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT. YOU GOT ME FOR MAKING
SURE THE FINANCE. WE NEED HIM ON
ONE BILL. YOU CAN RECESS FOR.
HEY. THE COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
OKAY. THE COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
BACK FROM RECESS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO, OPEN THE. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CONSENT CALENDAR?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CAN WE OPEN
THE ROLL, PLEASE? ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 15 ZERO 15
ZERO. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
433. I DON'T HAVE THAT HERE. CAN
WE OPEN THE ROLL AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, PLEASE. AS A
MEMBERS BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE.
NGUYEN SURDO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
THAT'S 12 TO 1. 12 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL NOW OPEN THE
ROLL AND FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
2069 GALLAGHER, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. MEMBERS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. BILL HAS 15 VOTES. THE
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE 2094 FLOOR. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. ABSENT. MEMBERS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. RUBIO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS 14 VOTES THAT BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR 2069.
GALLAGHER. THAT AGAIN SIX. YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M GOING OFF OF
NUMEROUS PAGES HERE WHERE I'M.
WE'VE DONE FIVE RIGHT. YEP.
YOU'RE ON SIX 2435 2435
MAIENSCHEIN ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS 510 TO 5. 10 TO
5. THAT BILL IS OUT. NUMBER
NINE. 2983. RODRIGUEZ. OPEN THE
ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. SMALLWOOD PHIBBUS
. IT'S 15. BILL HAS 15 VOTES.
IT'S OUT. WHERE ARE WE NOW,
GUYS? ITEM TEN. ITEM NUMBER TEN,
AB 3540, 25, 40, 25, 43. MEMBERS
BRADFORD BRADFORD, I SMALLWOOD
FAVORS. TEN FIVE. I DON'T HAVE.
ITEM 11. ITEM NUMBER 11. THAT'S
2589. PATTERSON. OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT. MEMBERS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
15. AGAIN. HOW MANY VOTES? 15.
BILLS OUT. ITEM 13. ITEM 13 AB
3203 AGUIAR-CURRY. ABSENT.
MEMBERS BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS IT'S 15 ZERO.
15 ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
NUMBER 14 369 DAVIS. ABSENT.
MEMBERS BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 15 ZERO 15
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. AB 3206.
ITEM NUMBER 15 MCKINNEY ABSENT.
MEMBERS. WILK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS 9494. THAT
BILL IS OUT. THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND SERGEANTS,
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. AND IN
SPITE OF, THE LENGTH IN TIME
THAT WE'VE HAD FOR A SHORT
AGENDA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE WORK. DODD. I.